[Musique]
Jean-Pierre Petit, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle
Sinkerview. Nous sommes en direct. On
vous reçoit dans le cadre de vos
activités passé, présent, futur
peut-être. Qui êtes-vous ? Est-ce que
vous pouvez vous présenter succintement
?
Bien mais j'ai 81 ans, je suis retraité.
Initialement, j'ai fait les études
d'ingénieur à l'École supérieure
d'aéronautique de Paris. Je suis diplômé
en 1961.
Après, j'ai travaillé comme ingénieur
d'essais de fusée à poudre. Et puis ma
fois après, j'ai je suis passé au CNRS,
on m'a demandé de fabriquer
l'électricité avec une espèce de canon à
plasma. Alors, j'ai fait ce qu'on me
demandait de faire. Malheureusement euh
ces recherches-là étaient en en en
désaffection à l'époque. Donc, j'ai
travaillé pendant 6 7 ans là-dessus.
J'ai obtenu de très bons résultats mais
au moment où le bateau coulait quoi.
C'est c'est on a envie de dire mais moi
ça marche. Non, ça a servi à rien. Bon
alors on racontera ça peut-être plus en
détail plus tard.
Et à ce moment-là, je suis passé à
l'astronophysique théorique.
Je me suis dit que si je voulais avoir
une continuité dans mon travail de
chercheur, c'était mieux d'être
théoricien parce que je serais pas
sensible aux aléas des fonctionnements,
des crédits, des choses comme ça. Donc
astrophysique théorique, après
géométrie, mathématique, informatique.
J'étais directeur de d'un centre
informatique Alexand Provence à l'époque
de la l'apparition des
micro-ordinateurs. On s'est beaucoup
amusé que ça et puis après je suis passé
à la cosmologie
et voilà et me voilà.
Euh sur internet, vous êtes très connu
pour la MHD.
Ouais.
Est-ce que vous pouvez expliquer à nos
auditeurs, à nos téléspectateurs
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que la MHD,
quelles sont les applications ? Quelles
sont les conséquences ? Alors, si vous
voulez euh il y a une chose, c'est que
là j'ai fait effectivement une vidéo en
en français qui a fait 200000 vues et
euh ça traite des nouvelles armes de
Poutine, mais c'est une un prétexte pour
présenter un petit peu mes travaux de
MHD. Et là, je suis en train de faire la
deuxième partie en anglais, mais j'en
ferai une doublage en français. Ça fera
de
MHD, ça veut dire quoi ? Magnéhodynam
magnéto hydrodynamique c'est quelque
chose qui a été inventé parad je sais
plus à à quelle époque c'est là la
manière d'agir sur un fluide avec un
champ électromagnétique
et effectivement on peut faire une
petite expérience avec un aimant avec
une pile on met de l'encre dans l'eau et
à ce momentl hop on voit l'eau qui file
comme ça c'est formidable. Bon et bien
moi j'ai été bombardé dans un projet de
MHD justement en 1963 à l'insul
mécanique des fluides et il s'agissait à
ce moment-là non pas d'agir sur un
fluide pour faire l'électricité mais
d'utiliser l'énergie cinétique du fluide
pour fabriquer l'électricité. Alors,
j'avais donc fabriqué un canon à plasma
avec une culasse comme ça. Il y avait un
long canon de 6 m de long et on tirait
des cartouches de gaz. Boum ! C'était
assez amusant quand on avait pas l'air
conditionné, quand il faisait très chaud
torsenu, on a l'impression d'être dans
un une tourelle de de curassé quoi. Les
g types qui ouvrent la ca qui rechargent
et cetera. Alors on tirait des
cartouches de gaz et des des carottes de
gaz d'argon à 10000° qui passaient à 2,m
7 dans un entrefer d'électro. Alors ça
c'était assez marrant parce que c'était
vraiment l'astuce française. On avait
pas d'argent donc on fabriquait un champ
de deux Tesla avec des condensateurs
quoi. Disons que ces recherches là ça
m'a amené à être en pointe en 2 ans
quoi. Et je peux dire quand même je suis
assez content parce que une année je
suis allé à un congrès en Allemagne et
les Russes ont dit actuellement c'est
les Français qui sont en pointe. Les
Français c'était moi. Donc le Congrès
suivant est lieu à Marseille dans mon
labo. C'est ça c'est voilà. Bon
les Russes vous ont mis ont remis une
médaille ou pas du tout ? Non
non ils n'ont pas mis de médaille mais
il y a c'est des gens formidables. Moi
j'ai j'ai été très copain avec ces
gens-là surtout il y a il y a une
finesse. C'est des vrais physiciens
quoi. J'ai j'aimerais apprécier ça. Donc
à ce moment-là on avait ce canon avec ce
gaz qui passe il arrive à une vitesse V.
Il y a un champ magnétique B. Alors, on
a un champ électromoteur et craque, ça
fait du courant et ça fait 2 MW avec une
tuère qui grosse comme une canette de
bière. Alors, effectivement, on se dit
je fabrique 2 MW mais pendant 50
m de secondes, c'est équivalent à une
lampe de poche comme ça par mais enfin
ça fait rien. Alors après la question
qu'on m'a posé, est-ce qu'on peut faire
marcher ce trucl avec deux températures
au lieu d'une ? Et ça, ça m'a amené à
devenir théoricien dans un espace à
cette dimension parce qu'il y a comme ça
qu'on s'en sort. la mécanique des
fluides, on se dit bon bah X y ZT ça va.
Non non là c'est plus subtil, il faut
rajouter trois dimensions
supplémentaires. C'était math et grâce à
ça, j'ai pu calculer une expérience et
ça a marché au premier essai. Ça c'est
quelque chose de formidable. Toutes mes
expériences ont marché au premier essai.
On me perçoit comme un théoricien en
fait j'étais un expérimentateur au
départ. Pas de problème. Donc à ce
moment-là, on charge mon canon à plasma,
on charge les condensateurs, tout est
prêt. Et moi je disais, on va avoir 7
8000 ampères. Mon ami lesquis n'y
croyait pas. Il avait mis le le
l'enregistrement beaucoup plus bas. Paf,
on a les spots qui partent à la
verticale. Finalement, on a ça et hop,
on obtient ces ces mégaw électriques
avec un gaz qui était à 6000°gr alors
que les électrons étaient à 10000. On
avait jamais fait ça. Alors, je
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un gaz
bitempérature ? Et ben, c'est un tube
fluorescent. Un tube fluorescent, vous
mettez la main dessus, c'est pas
brûlant. Donc, vous avez un gaz qui est
qui est à quelques dizaines de degrés.
Par contre, les électrons sont à
plusieurs milliers de degrés. C'est ça
qui fait qu'il y a de la lumière. Donc,
on appelle ça un système hors
d'équilibre. Et là, c'est de l'ord
d'équilibre dense avec un plasma. Alors,
j'ai réussi à faire ça et je me rappelle
qu'à l'époque mes collègues, on a fait
ça d'une matinée, hein, ils étaient
sceptiques. J'ai dit non, on va rajouter
3 % de gaz carbonique, les électrons
vont rentrer en collision avec les
molécules, ça va les refroidir, il y
aura plus rien. On fait l'essai, ça
marche au poil. Tu es 11h du matin, je
dis OK, on va déjeuner, c'est fini. On
avait fait 5 si essais, c'était dans la
poche. Voilà, c'était c'est assez
satisfaisant de de discuter avec la
nature et qu'elle vous réponde gentiment
comme ça. Voilà.
Les applications au niveau de la
propulsion, du déplacement.
Alors, d'abord c'était pour fabriquer de
l'électricité hein. Et alors ce système
là, la imagen justement, il y a eu un
énorme effort qui a été fait dans les
années 60. Ça avait commencé par les
anglais et puis les Russes parce que
pourquoi faire un générateur MHD ? parce
qu'il y a un rendement de 60 % au lieu
de 40 avec les les turbines à gaz.
Alors, vous rendez compte, vous avez de
l'énergie qui sort d'un réacteur
nucléaire, qui sort de de d'hydrocarbure
et avec ça, vous faites 20 %
d'électricité en plus. Vous rendez
compte de l'argent qu'il y avait
derrière. Alors, tout le monde s'est mis
là-dedans. Et pourquoi ça a foiré ? Mais
parce que les gaz sont des pauvres
conducteurs d'électricité.
Quand on a par exemple, il y avait des
systèmes où on faisait cracher de
l'énergie avec une chambre de
combustion, il y avait une tuyère, une
tuillère supersonique. Alors, on rajouta
du sésium. Le sésium c'est ce qui
sionise le plus mais tous les calculs
montraient que il fallait au moins
3000°gr. Et 3000°gr, c'est pas
technologique. On fait pas une
installation industrielle avec des
3000°,
c'est la température du filet d'une
lampe électrique. C'est pas commode.
Bon, alors c'est là qu'on a essayé
d'imaginer qu'on puisse faire un gaz
d'électron à 3000°gr et puis un gaz de
de neutre beaucoup plus bas. Et c'est là
qu'il y a un petit bonhomme qui
s'appelait Velikov qui est devenu
vice-président de la comie des sciences
en 1964. Son patron Shenling l'a amené à
un congrès en Angleterre et euh il a dit
voilà, je suis venu avec un jeune
étudiant Vikov, il a quelque chose à
vous raconter et Vikov a fait les
calculs et montré qu'il y avait une
instabilité pas possible qu'elle tout
par terre. C'est incroyable. Il
est arrivé comme le porteur de mauvaise
nouvell et tous les générateurs sont
devenus instables. Voilà et ça ça a
foutu en l'air toute la MHD. on a fini
par abandonner à la fin des années 60 et
moi, je suis le seul à avoir fait d'une
expérience où j'arrivais à matraquer
cette instabilité. C'est pour ça que les
Russes ont trouvé ça super. Donc je me
rappelle ce que disait euh Golouf, tu
apportes le remède mais le malade est
déjà mort. Vous voyez, c'est le moment
où on dit voilà j'ai j'ai résolu le
problème mais tout le monde abandonne.
Voilà donc fabrication d'électricité.
Puis alors accessoirement et bien ce
canon à plasma on pouvait l'utiliser
pour accélérer à plasma. Et alors ça
c'est extrêmement spectaculaire. Vous
avez un truc qui rentre à 2,7 km et 10
cm plus loin, il est à 8 kmes. On a un
gain de 5000 de 5 km/ir
sur les gaz c'est un coup de pied pas
possible. Je donne un exemple. Prenez
les moteurs du Concorde hein, vous les
videz, vous mettez un champ d'un Tesla
sur le côté, c'est pas énorme. Vous
mettez un courant d'un ampère par cm²,
ça fait 10000 ampères par mètre carré.
vous avez une force d'une tonne par m³.
Donc autrement dit, vous allez accélérer
la l'air à 800g. Donc tout d'un coup,
c'est l'idée que avec cette MHD, on a
une mécanique des fluides. On dit au
gaz, tu vas à droite, tu vas à gauche,
tu discutes pas. Ça c'est ça c'est le
truc fondamental. Voilà. Al après bon
tout
faut-il encore résister à ces
accélérations ? Non.
Faut-il encore résister à ces
accélation.
Mais le gaz, on lui donne pas son avis,
quoi.
Allez dire à un mécanicien des fluides,
voyez, j'ai un truc comme ça, je vais
faire tac tac. Tu dis c'est pas
possible. ça va décoller. Non non, le
gaz, on lui dit "Fais ceci, fais cela".
On vous connaît aussi euh pour la
question OVNI.
Bah accessoirement, alors si vous
voulez, qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
Voyez, j'avais donc ce générateur MHD et
puis par rapport à des tas d'autres gens
qui avaient des problèmes de
conductivité électrique comme j'avais
c'est de l'argon c'est pas conducteur
d'électricité mais à 10000°gr si c'est
très conducteur. Donc il y avait une
très forte interaction et quand ce
plasma arrivait dans la tunière ben si
on produisait l'électricité ça veut dire
qu'on transformait son énergie cinétique
en électricité. Donc on le ralentissait
mais on le ralentissait tellement que ça
faisait une onde de choc. Autrement dit,
j'avais une tuyère 5 cm par 5 cm droite
et il y avait une onde de choc droite
simplement à cause des forces
électromagnétiques. Et là, je me suis
dit si je peux créer une onde de choc
avec des ondes électromagnétiques, je
dois pouvoir l'enlever d'un profil. Tout
est parti de là. Autrement dit, on a un
vol supersonique avec des z ondes de
choc et ces ondes de choc et ben on va
les enlever. Alors évidemment, il y a un
problème qui apparaît immédiatement. Il
y a des gens qui disent "Bah moi, j'ai
vu passer un truc qui allait à une
vitesse folle. puis il faisait pas de
bruit. Donc sujet ovenni.
Vous avez aussi fait tout un protocole
pour recueillir des preuves, pour
récolter des herbes par terre.
Oui, enfin là, je veux dire,
vous avez fait aussi
centrons interview sur la science. On va
pas s'embarquer dans ce sujet
aujourd'hui,
on va centrer l'interview sur les
questions qu'on vous pose.
Ouais.
Donc le le vous avez aussi propagé des
bonnets pour téléphone portable.
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ? Voilà,
petits machins. Disons que ce sujet
OVNi, il a été très mal étudié quoi.
Alors, c'est vrai que les gens savent
pas quoi faire. Ils prennent des photos,
ils prennent des films, maintenant il
peut y avoir des faux en pagaille.
N'importe qui peut fabriquer un faux
truc. Alors là, ben il y a un petit
machin comme ça qu'on met sur son
téléphone portable et puis lorsqu'on on
tire sur la le tiroir comme ça, voilà,
tac, et ben on met un réseau devant et
ça transforme l'image en en spectre. On
peut prendre le spectre de l'objet. Et
ça, c'est extrêmement intéressant parce
que par exemple, vous avez des gens qui
disent "Oh, c'est des lanternes
thaïlandaises." Mais si c'est des
lanternes thaïlandaises, ça veut dire
qu'il y a un hydrocarbure qui brûle.
Donc si je prends une photo de ce truclà
que je trouve le spectre d'hylocarbure,
c'est peut-être une lanterne
thaïlandaise. Si c'est un phénomène
naturel, il y a forcément de la vapeur
d'eau. Donc je vais trouver le spectre
de la vapeur d'eau, hein. Maintenant, si
c'est un truc comme du lithium ou je ne
sais trop quoi, là c'est plus une
lanterne thaïlandaise, c'est plus un
phénomène naturel. Voilà. Ah,
évidemment, il y aura peut-être défaut.
Alors, le truc, c'est d'arriver à à
répondre ça à grande échelle. On va y
arriver. On va y arriver.
Combien ça coûte ? Ah euh pour le moment
euh j'ai un garçon qui travaille dans
une usine, il s'appelle on trouvera son
nom sur mon site, Joël de la sauce. Euh
8 € euh porort compris pour avoir ce
petit match. 8 €.
Vous prenez euh un gain dessus ? Pas du
tout. Euh vous prenez un gain dessus
sur 8 € rigoler. Mais je prends rien du
tout. Au contraire, moi je trouve que il
y a une chose si vous voulez c'est ça
qui est Non mais attendez, il y a un
truc c'est que
c'est fabriqué avec une imprimante 3D,
un truc comme ça hein. L'imprimante 3D
c'est très récent, un truc pareil et
c'est un bouleversement technologique
extraordinaire. Ça va envahir, vous
savez, c'est comme l'imprimante. Un
jour, tout le monde aura une imprimante
3D chez lui. Alors à ce moment-là, moi
j'ai dit bah ce fichierlà, il faut le
mettre en accès libre dans internet.
Donc ce gars-là fabrique ça mais tout le
monde peut le fabriquer. Ah il y a déjà
des types qui fabriquent leur machin qui
qui le modifient. C'est en accès libre.
C'est c'est dans le domaine public ce
trucl. Voilà.
Est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler du
rapport cométat ? Oh moi je veux bien
mais si vous voulez je sais pas mais
tout ce qui a pu se faire comme ça le
report cométage je sais plus quand ça
date. Ce sont des officiers supérieurs
en général qui tous avaient été témoins
du phénomène qui ont se senti un petit
peu obligés de faire un un dossier. Et
si vous remarquez à la fin du rapport
cométa qu'est-ce que dit ce brave
général d'I ? Il dit euh les Américains
ont pris ça au sérieux, ils en ont tiré
des trucs pour faire des armes. Faudrait
qu'on puisse faire pareil. Et c'est là
que vous voyez la le hicelle est la
motivation de l'intérêt des gens pour ce
sujet, c'est fabriquer des armements.
Donc voilà le sens du rapport comé. Donc
c'est l'Institut des Hautes études à la
défense nationale qui avait commandé ça.
Bah oui. Bon
c'est un rapport qui fait combien de
pages ? Vous l'avez lu ?
Bien sûr, bien sûr. Mais ça date de 90,
un truc comme ça.
Est-ce que ça a fait du bruit ? Est-ce
que ça a fait quelque chose ?
Ah oui, ça c'est marrant. Mais je veux
dire, ce qui est extraordinaire, c'est
quand on regarde ce rapport, il y a pas
de données scientifiques là-dedans. Moi,
j'avais pourtant essayé d'entrer en
contact avec en disant "Si vous voulez,
je peux vous filer des billes
scientifiques." Voilà des braves
officiers supérieurs qui sont partis au
combat avec des fusils sans cartouches,
hein. Ils sont arrivés avec leur bonne
volonté en disant "C'est très
important." Puis il y avait rien dans ce
rapport, il y avait rien. Alors ça a eu
les journalistes s'en sont moqués,
rappelez-vous.
Voilà.
Vous vous avez continué vos recherches
dans ce domaineel ?
Écoutez, moi je fais des recherches de
MHD, je fais des recherche
d'astrophysique théorique, je fais des
recherches de cosmologie. J'aimerais
bien qu'on parle de ça.
On a tout le temps.
On a tout le temps. D'accord.
On a tout le temps. On a une question
internet qui nous dit planète humau,
qu'est-ce que c'est ? Les humites
qu'est-ce que c'est ?
C'est reparti. Bah écoutez, j'ai sorti
un bouquin début 2017.
Et là maintenant, il y a un deuxième qui
va sur le mois de septembre. Vous allez
avoir les réponses à ces questions quoi.
Alors, mais si vous voulez, c'est
l'aspect anecdotique des problèmes. Moi,
vous savez, je suis avant tout un
scientifique et je vous dirai la chose
suivante. Si tout se passe bien, ce sera
la première interview où je serai
présenté comme un scientifique.
Mais ça répond pas à ma question, du
moins à la question d'internet.
Bon bah,
j'avoue que j'ai pas à me cacher,
j'ai été très inspiré par ces documents
pendant 40 ans. C'est pas mal. Voilà.
Ces documents venaient d'où ?
C'est un canular, c'est pas un canular.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Je me rappelle, j'avais un collègue
astrophysicien qui me dit "Tu sais, il y
a des types en Espagne qui reçoit des
lettres qui sont écrites par des
extraterrestres en qui prétendent
extraterrestres." Bon, OK. Alors, moi,
j'ai trouvé ça très amusant. Puis quand
j'ai eu les premières feuilles
là-dedans, j'ai trouvé quand même
c'était assez rusé. Donc j'ai eu envie
d'aller plus loin. Et puis c'est une
histoire à la Spielberg quoi. Vraiment,
il y a de quoi faire un film là-dedans.
C'est pas possible. C'est passionnant.
Mais vous savez comment dire ? Moi je
trouve que si on fait pas les choses
avec passion, on s'emmerde quoi.
Franchement, j'ai eu une chance folle
d'être dans ces histoires là.
Franchement, il y a des scientifiques,
ils sont là en train de se bagarrer avec
leurs collègues dans les couloirs. Moi,
je suis allé sur le terrain, j'ai j'ai
rencontrer des tas de gens passionnants.
J'ai je me suis trouvé avec ces
informations absolumentissantes. C'est
trop drôle. C'est un film de Suilberg,
je vous sûr.
Vous pouvez rentrer un peu plus dans le
détail quand même.
Ben, je vous dirais euh moi, j'ai déjà
écrit ça dans dans plusieurs livres. Euh
il y a 1/3 Einstein, 1/3 Spielberg et
uners Max Brotherers.
et on va il y a on en rajoute peut-être
un mais on peut pas. Mais est-ce que
est-ce que c'est c'est un canular ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Mais comment dire les informations les
informations qui sont dans ce document
sont de haut niveau et sont
exploitables. Voilà, c'est ça que je
peux dire. Je l'ai toujours dit et moi
si vous voulez je me suis c'était
présenté comment ? C'était
Ah, écoutez, vous lisez par exemple,
vous savez, mes braves petitens, vous
devriez réfléchir au fait que l'univers,
il y a il a un frère jumeau, un univers
jumeau dans lequel le temps va à
l'envers, il estantiomorphe,
les charges électriques sont opposées,
les galaxies sont pas foutues pareil,
elles sont pas dans le même nombre, des
informations comme celle-là. Ah ! Alors,
on regarde ce truclà
et moi, je me rappelle ma conviction
s'est formée en 1977 parce que à
l'époque, je faisais de la cosmologie
avec ce qu'on appelle l'équation de
Vlasov.
Alors, en ce moment, j'ai pris deux
équations de Vlasov couplé. J'ai inversé
le temps, j'ai inversé l'espace, j'ai
inversé les charges électriques. Croc,
tout s'est arrangé. Oh là là, je me suis
dit nombre de Dieu. Le type qui a écrit
ces phrases, il savait que ça
fonctionnait. Mais c'est une conviction
de théoricien qui n'était pas
communicable.
Voilà. Donc
pourquoi pas communicable ?
Bah sinon un mathématicien ou un
théoricien. Et alors après bon bah tout
ce qui en découle. Qu'est-ce que vous
voulez ? Regardez par exemple, on va en
parler de cette histoire du modèle
Génus.
Est-ce que c'était un canular ou pas ?
Non, ça n'est pas un canular. Maintenant
qu'il y ait des composantes quel
lunaresque, c'est probable. Il y a par
exemple un document qui est arrivé avant
la guerre du golfe où à ce moment-là la
lettre disait "Vous savez Saddam Husem
est à 18 mois d'avoir la bombe à
hydrogène. Il a envoyé des commandos
dans les villes avec des virus modifiés.
Tout ça c'est faux. Voilà une lettre qui
est un faux complet. Mais il y avait le
petit détail qui faisait vrai. On disait
les Américains ont une arme secrète qui
leur permet avec un satellite de se
localiser dans le désert. C'était le
GPS. À l'époque, c'était pas trop connu.
Alors, qui est-ce qui a fait ce document
? Vous savez, en latin, on dit il fait
cuit prodeste. Celui qui l'a fait, c'est
celui à qui ça profite. Bon, alors
chercher qui est-ce qu' aurait pu mettre
un truc pareil ? C'est vrai, tout à
l'heure, vous parliez de DGSE. Je pense
que dans les services secrets, quelque
fois il y a des gens qui s'amusent. Il y
a des gens qui s'amusent. Ils ont envie
d'utiliser un truc comme ça.
D'accord. Donc c'est c'est pour vous,
c'est on vous a intoxiqué, ça venait
d'une puissance étrangère, ça venait des
petits hommes verts. Ça venait de qui ?
Mais peu importe, le problème c'est ce
que ça a donné le résultat. Regardez, il
y a 3 4 jours, j'ai eu l'avis
d'acceptation d'un article de 14 pages
dans Aastrophysique and Space Science
avec des résultats scientifiques
droitement intéressants. Vous savez ce
que disent les scientifiques à propos de
mes travaux ? Moi, j'ai vu des gens dans
des conférences comme ça quand on les
interpelle à propos du modèle Janus.
Oui, ce modèle Janus n'a pas encore reçu
la validation de la part de la
communauté scientifique. Alors, c'est
quoi la validation ? assez se conformer
aux observations. Là, vous avez cet
article don je vous ai donné des copies,
des confirmations, il a une tripe, on
pourra en parler tout à l'heure.
Voilà. Ben voilà, mais je crois pas
qu'on puisse faire un gros plan
là-dessus. Bon, voilà. Voilà cet
article. Bon, OK. Bah, cet article là,
des confirmations sur mail, il y en a il
y en a toutes les pages, quoi. Bon,
alors maintenant,
ça a été publié chez qui ?
Astrophysic and Space Science. Vous
savez, il y a modern physique stat,
astrophysique Spice Science, nouveau
Chimo. Il faut publier dans des revues
de haut niveau. Ça n'a aucun intérêt.
Vous savez que maintenant il y a une
tapée de la revue internet. Qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire pour faire une revue ?
Dans le temps, il fallait de l'argent
parce que pour faire une revue, il
fallait quelqu'un qui tape les textes
puis après, il fallait les imprimer puis
alors il fallait diffuser ça. Tandis que
maintenant avec le numérique, une revue,
c'est deux assistants dans une fac.
Alors ça un nom euh la science avancée,
la physique. Moi, on reçoit deux fois
par semaine des propositions disant nous
sommes intéressés par vos travaux,
pouvez-vous nous faire un article ? Puis
alors on s'enseigne. C'est encore un
truc bidon. Il y en a une tapé de truc
bidon.
Maintenant, les revues de haut niveau,
c'est pas commode, hein.
Dites-moi, la la communauté
scientifique,
beaucoup de journalistes, y compris
Laurent Alexandre qui vous appelle la
ricaille de la science. Pourquoi
pourquoi pourquoi ces gens-là vous
considèrent comme un charlot ou qu'un un
illuminé ou quelque chose ? Vous savez,
il y a un truc qui s'appelle les
séminaires, hein, les séminaires
scientifiques dans des laboratoires.
Tout à l'heure, quelqu'un disait que
j'avais un mauvais caractère, mais quand
quelqu'un justement est désagré,
caractère de merde,
caractère de merde, si vous voulez.
D'accord. Bah à ce moment-là, on on Moi,
je me rappelle, ça a commencé là,
c'était en en je sais plus en quelle
année, au début des années 80, j'avais
un copain physicien théoricien, il était
au laboratoire de physique théorique de
Marseille et il a dit à ses collègues,
"Écoutez, vous arrêtez pas de dire pique
pendez-le
et plantez-le, nom de Dieu."
Ah ben c'est ce qu'on va faire
aujourd'hui,
si vous voulez. Mais il y a Oui, mais il
y a personne. Vous parliez, j'ai pas de
contradicteur, je demande que ça.
Indiquez-moi la le colisé, je rentre.
Est-ce que est-ce que le fait que vous
vous intéressiez aux OVNIS, que vous
ariez que que vous avez reçu des papiers
un peu sulfureux de de gens qui se
présentaient comme des extraterrestres,
est-ce que tout ça n'a pas participé au
fait de vous jeter aux oubliettes ?
Écoutez, moi j'ai j'ai inventé un mot
dans le temps qui s'appelle la
cosmotrouille.
La cosmotrouille en fait ce qui se
passe, qu'est-ce qui fait peur chez les
gens ? Mais que ce soit les
scientifiques, les politiques, les
religieux, ils ont la trouille parce que
c'est déstabilisant. Il y a pas pire. Je
crois que le sujet c'est le tabsolu.
C'est déstabilisant pour eux de d'avoir
une personne en face.
Mais vous vous rendez pas compte
qui reçoit des papiers. Mais
c'est pas ça. Mais mais vous est-ce que
vous êtes prêt à accepter l'idée qu'il y
a des gens qui viennent chez nous, qui
se promènent comme ça comme des fleurs,
qui en savent surtout beaucoup plus que
nous ? Regardez actuellement les
exoplanètes. Ah mon dieu, on a 2500
exoplanètes. Oh la vie existe sûrement.
Je me rappelle à jour, il y avait un
scientifique qui ont questionnait qui
disait "Oui, bien sûr, la vie existe
mais alors au niveau bactérien mais
alors après la dernière la la dernière
barrière c'est oui, ils sont là mais
c'est loin, ils peuvent pas venir à
cause de la vitesse de la lumière." Et
vous allez voir, on va en parler tout à
l'heure, le modèle genus, il y a deux
vitesses de la lumière. Pour les espèces
positives, c'est 300000 km/s et puis
pour les espèces négatives, c'est 3
millions. Ça va 10 fois plus vite et les
distances sont souvent plus courte.
Autrement dit, qu'est-ce qui dérange
dans ce truclà ? C'est que la
conclusion, c'est les voyages
interstelles sont non impossibles.
Qu'est-ce qui dérange dans Jean-Pierre
Petit ?
Quoi ?
Qu'est-ce qui dérange dans Jean-Pierre
Petit ?
Non, c'est pas Jean-Pierre Petit qui
dérange, c'est cette idée.
C'est cette idée. Comment se fait-il
qu'on peut pas aller dans un séminaire
et parler d'un truc comme ça ? C'est la
science se refuse des expériences de
pensée.
Mais je sais pas mais je je vois par
exemple dès qu'on veut parler, vous
savez les scientifiques, ce sont des
moines froussards, ils veulent pas.
Il y a des tas de sujets qu'onaborde
pas.
Lesquels ?
Mais tout
le le vous savez, moi j'ai fait un
dessin mais
écoutez, j'ai fait un dessin dans la
bande dessinique qui s'appelle le mur du
silence. rapp il y a un lampadaire et
puis il y a un type qui est là avec une
bousse blanche et l'entelu dit "Mais
mais là où vous cherchez il y a rien."
Oui mais au moins il y a de la lumière.
Mais c'est ça.
Vous êtes fêé
quoi.
Vous êtes féé vous laissez passer la
lumière.
Vous êtes fêé donc vous vous laissez
passer la lumière.
Fé
on dit on dit que les félés laissent
passer la lumière.
Je sais pas ce que ça veut dire. Non non
non. Moi je j'avoue que je je cherche
partout là où il y a de la lumière et là
où il y a l'obscurité. Quels sont quels
sont les sujets qu'on se refuse dans les
communautés scientifiques ?
Le sujet au OVNI, puis alors après, je
sais pas l'évolution, le darwinisme,
puis alors après tout ce qui a trait euh
regardez par exemple pour la communauté
scientifique euh la pensée, la
conscience mais c'est une ce sont des
réactions enzymatiques. N'allez pas vous
imaginer qu'il puisse y avoir un monde
intangible. Voilà.
Qu'est-ce que vous entendez par un monde
intangible ?
Bah écoutez,
est-ce que vous avez un ami imaginaire ?
Quoi ?
Vous avez un ami imaginaire ? J'ai un
ami imaginaire.
Non mais si vous voulez euh
croyez en Dieu,
je vais répondre à tout ça. Euh mais on
on met la la charrue avant les bœu. Si
on pouvait parler du modèle Janus, après
vous verrez les développements.
Et Jean-Pierre, on va en parler de ton
modèle Janus. N'énerén pas, ça fait 20
minutes qu'on interview. On se détend.
Bon alors euh disons que cette problème
de la conscience c'est ce qu'il y a de
plus passionnant.
Et au mois d'octobre 2016 est arrivée
une idée
et ça constitue des travaux dans lequel
je suis embarqué depuis tout ce temps-là
avec des copains mathématiciens.
Et à ce moment-là, il y a pas deux
espèces de masses, il y en a quatre. Et
ça débouge sur un univers dans lequel on
a un espace réel, un temps réel et puis
il y a un autre espace avec un espace
imaginaire, un temps imaginaire
mathématiquement s'entend avec des
masses imaginaires.
Donc ça c'est une métaphysique
théorique. Ça c'est joli comme tout.
C'est c'est une aventure un truc comme
ça.
Pourquoi pourquoi le darwinisme et
l'évolution vous vous en avez parlé là ?
On va pas aborder. C'est moi je vous
on a 2 heures là. On on se détend.
D'accord. Mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que moi ce qu'il y a de terrible, je me
dis bon sang, j'ai 81 ans et j'ai envie
de dire aux jeunes mais bon sang
bougez-vous, c'est passionnant si vous
voulez. Je suis le Christophe Colomb du
3e millénaire. Voilà. Allez, on va
découvrir l'Amérique, découvrir le
nouveau monde, un nouveau monde
scientifique. Pour
pour c pour certains, vous êtes un peu
le professeur tournesol sous aldol.
Bah écoutez, le professeur tournesol,
discutons de ça en séminaire. Vous
savez, j'ai jamais perdu un combat en
séminaire. Ce qui se passe, c'est que
lorsqu'on est en séminaire, les gens
vous agressent. Ah, c'est
extraordinaire. Mais que ce soit ça ou
des congrès, ben je me rappelle un
congrès scientifique, il y a un grand
professeur américain qui dit à propos
d'un travail d'astrophysique euh le
travail qui a présenté ce français a
l'air très intéressant mais et là s'il
contredit le théorème des dington et moi
je réponds si vous l'appliquez
correctement ça ne vous arriverait pas
et je fais ça et le type poum
j'ai le théorème facile
l'évolution le darwinisme pourquoi c'est
difficile
non mais je suis pas spécialiste de
l'évolution mais vous voyez bien qu'il y
a des tas de sujets comme ça on peut pas
en parler
c'est pointu quoi. Qu'est-ce que c'est
que le vivant et tout ça là ? Mais c'est
pas je ne suis pas un spécialiste de
tout. Simplement vous savez bien qu'il y
a des sujets que que les gens n'aiment
pas aborder. C'est tout.
Aborder pour quelle raison ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est que la science ? la
démarche scientifique,
on crée des modèles, on est à
l'intérieur d'un paradigme, on
interprète des phénomènes, on en
prévoit, on on C'est ça, il y a un
dialogue comme ça. Maintenant, quand
vous êtes face à des phénomènes qui sont
pas reproductibles par exemple comme les
phénomènes paranormaux, là c'est
vachement embêtant.
Qu'est-ce que vous entendez par
phénomènes paranormaux ?
Ben justement, les phénomènes qui sont
pas reproductibles.
Vous avez des exemples ?
Hm. Bah des la télépathie euh choses
comme ça. Mais il y a une chose par moi
j'ai un ami.
Voilà, vous avez un gars qui qui a fait
une série de DVD, c'est Stéphan Alix.
Moi je trouve c'est pas mal ce qu'il a
fait. Bon alors un jour Stéphan Alix, il
est là puis
il a Ah bon ? Vous trouverez et il est
là. Enfin c'est un médium qui lui met
les mains et Alix est là en disant "Oh,
il m'attire, il m'attire." Bon, moi j'ai
un ami guérisseur, un type très sympa.
Il m'a dit un ami guérisseur.
Mais oui, mais oui, mais oui, mais oui.
Alors, mon ami Gilbert
Gilbertat et Gilbertat a dit "Moi, je
sais faire ça." "Ah bon, tu sais faire
ça ? Comment ça se fait ?" Alors, il se
met derrière moi, il met ses mains, "Oh,
on est attiré." Al, je me dis "Bon, ma
femme pareil, un ami pareil, ça marche."
Alors là, je me suis dit, il faut
absolument
que vous nous donniez votre numéro de
dealer.
Non.
Quand on est face à un phénomène comme
ça, il faut le prouver. Moi, je dirais
même on va faire ça avec les éhéticiens,
vous savez, les éhéticiens qui qui pense
que tout ça c'est de la fouise. Ben,
vous avez une façon de savoir si ça
marche ou pas. Ça s'appelle le choix
forcé, hein. Alors, le choix forcé dans
une espance comme ça, on va prendre un
sujet n'importe lequel et puis mon ami
Gilbert se mettra derrière et au lieu de
faire un essai, il va en faire deux. Et
dans ces trucs là, alternativement le
signal sera absent ou présent. C'est vu
qu'on ne demande pas est-ce que vous
sentez ? On demande dans quel essai ça
se trouvait. Alors, vous avez un
magnétopen qui dit premier essai 2e
essai puis alors on enregistre la
réponse du gars. Et moi, j'ai fait des
expériences comme ça en psychologie
expérimentale il y a il y a 40 ou 50
ans. Euh par exemple sur le plan visuel,
on vous présente un signal lumineux puis
il y a pratiquement rien. Alors on est
dans une chambre obscure et puis on dit
premier essai deè essai puis on dit j'ai
rien vu puis on répond et on s'aperçoit
qu'on fait 70 % de bonnes réponses.
Parce que si vous faites 50 % de bonnes
réponses, c'est que vous percevez rien
que c'est aléatoire. Donc on va faire ça
avec Gilbert. Il faut absolument qu'on
montre cette expérience et lui ça va
être 100 % de bonne réponse. Il tire pas
de problème. Et ça après il va falloir
se battre pour publier ça dans une revue
scientifique car ce sera une démarche
scientifique. Vous êtes bien d'accord ?
Oui. Non,
on n'est pas là pour juger.
On n'est pas là pour juger. Nous, on
pose juste les questions. Est-ce que
vous comprenez qu'avec tout ça on vous
perçoivent un peu comme un allumé ? Un
Mais j'espère à l'allumé, il faut avoir
la lumière quoi.
Faut être fêé
fé fêé.
Non mais passionné, vous savez moi il y
a un truc quand je vois la science
actuelle si je voulais résumer ma
critique je dirais elle manque de
souffle épique. Mais la science doir du
souffle épique dans une pipe. Quand vous
montez une expérience que ça marche,
c'est formidable tout ça hein. Et là
vous voyez les gens ils sont là avec
leur matière sombre, leur énergie noire,
ils se tricotent des super chaussettes
avec le super corde. C'est emmerdant à
mourir.
La complexité est emmerdante.
La complexité, qu'est-ce que ça
s'appelle la complexité ? Non, c'est
c'est c'est du langage.
Est-ce que vous avez un point de vue sur
l'éducation ?
Sur l'éducation.
Un point de vue sur l'éducation ? Bah,
il y a il y a une phrase que j'aime
bien, c'est la connaissance important
parce que quand on la donne, on peut
plus la reprendre. Je pense qu'il faut
que la connaissance arriveille vers les
gens. Il faut leur dire la vérité.
Alors, c'est pas là que j'ai fait 30
bandes dessinées. Euh, ça se diffusait
très mal parce que l'éditeur les faisait
trop cher et tout ça. Un moment, je les
ai mis en accès libre. Elles sont sur
mon site savoir sans frontière wwsir
d'union tradunionfrontière.com.
Là, vous avez 30 BD. Alors, je me
rappelle comment ça s'est passé. Une
année, j'avais commencé mon site
internet et puis ma fois ça me prenait
beaucoup de temps puis j'avais des
problèmes d'argent. Alors, un moment,
j'ai fait un petit ton. Vous savez, il y
avait le télétour. Donc j'ai demandé aux
gens, pourriez pas m'envoyer un peu de
sous parce que je m'en sors pas. Ils
m'ont envoyé de l'argent.
Moi, je me suis dit bon,
vous avez pris combien ?
Oh, à l'époque, je dirais que oh quand
même, j'avais demandé, je sais pas 5
6000 € ou un truc comme ça, ils m'en ont
eu le double. Alors, les gens mais il
est formidable, tu vas changer ta
voiture. Non non, j'ai demandé ça. Ce
qui reste, on va créer une association.
On a créé savoir sans frontière et ça a
été mis dans la caisse et avec ça on
s'est mis à payer les traducteurs. Ben
là, vous savez combien il y a de bandes
décidées téléchargeables ? 510
extraordinaire
et dans 40 langues.
Et ça ça c'est une aventure formidable.
Vous avez les traducteurs qui disent "Je
suis fier de participer à ça." Et ça
c'est la connaissance. C'est non
seulement la connaissance mais c'est la
défense des langues des gens. Parce que
vous savez vous avez la science
maintenant c'est en anglais hein. C'est
en anglais. Moi je me pense à un truc,
c'est que il y a des malgaches là de de
Madagascar, ils ont traduit mes vont
décidé en malgache. Ils ont été obligés
d'inventer des mots.
Bon, les armes russes, histoire de
changer de sujet.
Ah, vous allez vous embarquer là-dedans.
Alors, disons que la MHD
alors je vais vous dire pourquoi on vous
on vous aujourd'hui
vous êtes une légende sur internet quand
même. Vous avez un certain public et et
euh
mais je suis gentil comme tout moi.
Pourquoi est-ce
des fois vous êtes bien allumé quand
même ? D'ailleurs, on demand
Ouais. Ouais. On va demander à notre
plateforme de facting de
vous allez faire voter les gens. Qui
est-ce qui vote pour que petit soit
allumé ? Enfin
non non, on les fait pas voter, on les
fait fact.
On vérifie si vous dites des conneries
ou pas. Donc pour dire la pour dire la
suite, on a vu une vidéo de vous qui
doit bien dater d'une vingtaine d'années
ou d'une quinzaine d'années.
Ouais.
Et vous et vous parliez de de MHD, de
mode de propulsion.
Ouais.
Et nous à l'époque
vous regardez avec un intérêt certain
parce que on trouvait que c'était un peu
la la science fiction un peu d'allumer
et cette vidéo quand même nous est
restée en tête et quand on a vu la vidéo
de Poutine
sur la présentation des armes, on s'est
dit hm le vieux dit peut-être pas que
des conneries
ou il a énormément de chance
donc on a décidé de vérifier si vous
aviez de la chance ou si vous racontiez
que des conneries. Alors
donc vous êtes là, les armes russes, la
vidéo de Poutine, ça vous a fait penser
à quoi ?
Alors il y a il y a un truc si vous
voulez, c'est j'avais fait un bouquin
sur sur les armes américaines et je me
rappelle il y avait un journaliste qui
s'appelle je plus son nom mais il avait
dit ce que dit petit c'est du délire
technologique. C'était vraiment ça
contre du délire technologique.
C'est un journaliste ou un scientifique
? C'est un journaliste aéronautique.
Non, ça vaut pas la peine de citer son
nom. Mais disons que
vous en prenez souvent dans la gueule
quand même.
Ah oui, complètement.
Genre genre
Ah ouais ouais ouais.
Vous devriez prendre des pilules.
Oui oui. Laurent Alexandre il va me
mettre sous médicament.
Oui. Non parce que si vous voulez il y a
une chose c'est que la MHD ça permet des
trucs fabuleux. Il urologue aussi hein.
Laurent Alexandre urologue oui euh moi
je sais pas très bien l'urologie mène à
tout à condition d'en sortir. Bah
déjà vous voyez voler à vitesse supers
sonic sans faire de de bang. D'abord il
y a une chose justement ce que vous
voyez il y a quoi dans le discours de
Poutine ? Qu'est-ce qu'il raconte ?
Alors, il y a plusieurs plans. D'abord,
il parle d'un missile de croisière à
propulsion nucléaire, hein, en disant
"Ce tru là, personne n ça." Alors, c'est
il dit il dit propulsion nucléaire.
Propulsion nucléaire. Exactement. Oui.
Oui. Propulsion nucléaire. Alors, si
vous voulez, la propulsion nucléaire,
c'est intéressant parce que vous avez
une euh euh une autonomie illimitée.
Quand vous avez un sous-marin nucléaire,
euh il marche pendant 10 ans avec la
même charge, il refait pas le plein.
C'est extraordinaire un truc comme ça.
C'est ça qui s'est passé avec le
Nautilus le jour où on a fait le premier
sous-marin à propulsion d'écléaire, il
avait plus de carburant. Il est pas la
peine de faire le plein. Voilà. Donc, si
on peut faire la même chose avec un
missile, c'est formidable. Et alors ce
qui est marrant c'est que je regardais
les échos dans la presse américaine avec
des grands journaux et il y avait un
type qui disait "C'est de la fouaise,
ils sont pas prêt de le faire marcher
leur missile à l'énergie nucléaire."
Maintenant vous allez sur internet, vous
cherchez le projet Plutôt PLU to Plutôt
pour dire Pluton, hein, c'est pas le
personnage de Walt Disney quoi. Bon et
alors le projet Plutôt c'est un slam.
Slam ça veut dire supersonic low
altitude missile myile. Bon et là vous
trouvez tout vous trouvez les plans de
ce machin. Vous trouver cinq vidéos qui
vous racontent toute l'histoire depuis
le début. Ça a été complètement
déclassifié. Alors qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé ? Et bien ça a démarré en 1955. En
1955 les Américains sont dire "On va
faire un missile à propulsion
nucléaire." Alors, on essayait de mettre
des des propulseurs nucléaires dans les
avions, hein. Imaginez justement, vous
avez des moteurs électrique et un
général, mais le rayonnement du réacteur
était tel qu'il fallait un tel blindage
de plomb qu'on pouvait pas mettre le
machin dans un avion. C'est beaucoup
trop lourd. Mais maintenant, si vous
mettez ça dans une arme, vous vous en
foutez que ça crache du rayonnement. Et
alors c'est léger,
il y a pas de pilote.
Il y a pas de pilote. Alors, le moteur
qui sont mis au point, ça fait 1 m de
diamètre, 1 m de long. Alors la
simplicité c'est extraordinaire. Ce sont
des tubes de céramique. L'air rentre par
un bout et sort par l'autre. Les tubes
sont à 1200°. On fait arriver l'air et
voilà le propulseur. Il y a pas de pièce
mobile, il y a rien. Fabuleux. Alors ce
réacteur, c'est comme un cœur de
réacteur. À l'intérieur vous avez des
barres de cadmium. Vous enlevez les
barres de cadmium, ça démarre. Tant que
les barres de cadmium sont dedans, ça
bouge pas. Donc quand on lâche un
missile comme ça, imaginez qu'on le
lâche d'avion ou quoi que ce soit, ben
on le largue quand il est à côté de
l'avion, il est pas radioactif. Une fois
qu'il est largué, il crache tant plus.
C'est même considéré même comme une
bombe à soit tout seul, un truc comme
ça. Parce que vous savez que dans un
réacteur nucléaire, il y a 50 kg
d'uranium. Il y a donc l'équivalent de
20 bombes atomiques. C'était c'est
vraiment la bombe sale par excellence.
Donc ces types-là conçoivent ce genre de
chos. Projet ultra secret évidemment qui
est développé au Laurence Liverboard
laboratobi. Alors dans les vidéo vous
verrez c'est assez marrant parce que
quand il ça ils avaient un petit peu les
jetons. Donc au moment où ils montent
leur réacteur c'est à l'intérieur de
murs de béton avec des tél des
télémanipulations et des caméras et tout
ça. Puis après c'est monté sur un un
wagon de chemin de fer. Pourquoi ? parce
qu'on envoie le truc à 45 km au cas ça
vous explosera la figure. Alors, ils ont
fait deux moteurs. Ils ont fait un
moteur qui s'appelle Tory 1 qui est un
truc de cette taille là qui est un
prototype. Mais le second le 2 et bien
c'est le propulseur de vol. Et si vous
allez voir les cinq vidéos, à la 5è
vidéo, le type disait "On a fait marcher
ce trucl pendant 300 secondes, c'est
opérationnel. Le stade suivant c'est les
essais en vol." Donc c'était prêt à
marcher. Alors c'était prêt à marcher.
C'était quoi ? et bien plutôt, c'était
un missile de 27 m de longde, 26 tonnes,
il y a évidemment pas de réservoir de
carburant, il y avait un système de
pilotage et puis ça emportait
éventuellement une bombe de de 20 m ou
alors plusieurs bombes de 2 m tonnes ou
alors plein de petites bombinettes de
300 m et ce trucl volait à Mac 35
Mac 35 à 100 m d'altitude. C'était un
missile de croisière.
Et ce trucl allait faire un petit tour
comme ça lâchant des bombes partout.
C'était vraiment c'était ça l'arme
américaine. Et à ce moment-là, il s'est
il était passé quelque chose en 57. Ça a
été spoutnicque tout d' parce que il y a
une chose merveilleuse 1957
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'année
géophysique internationale. Vous êtes
trop jeune pour avoir connu ça. Moi moi
j'étais étudiant. C'était formidable.
L'année géophilique internationale tous
les pays s'étaient unis pour aller
étudier la haute atmosphère. Alors, les
Américains avaient une fusée qui
s'appelait Vangward. Elle elle était
grande comme ça. Elle avait ce diamètre
là. Sans blague hein. Et les Russes
avaient leur simur cag dont la base ne
tiendrait pas dans v dans votre studio
quoi. Et à ce moment-là avec cette
fusée, ils ont commencé par lancer
Sputnik qui a fait bip bip, premier
satellite. Après, ils ont lancé la
chienne la IKA. Puis après, ça a été
Gaillaride, les Américains. Enfin, vous
avez vu le film les tofs des héros. Là,
ça retrace bien ce genre de chos.
Jean-Pierre, revenons aux armes russes.
Bah oui, mais attends,
la présentation de Poutine.
Ouais. Bon, alors donc j'ai j'en parle
puisque je parle de ce missile de
croisière. Donc ce missile de croisière,
il était en projet en 55 et en 1965 le
moteur était opérationnel.
Lesjà les gars auraient continué.
L'année suivante, le truc était
opérationnel au point de vue de
l'aérodynamique et ça a été arrêté. Donc
qu'est-ce qu' a fait Poutine ? Il a
repris ce projet. simplement c'est un
petit machin qui fait 6 m de long et le
réacteur il est gros comme ça seulement
ce trucl ça vole à tr personne n'a dit
que c'était supers sonique. Moi je le
dis c'est un truc qui vole à Mac 35 qui
va être à 100 m d'altitude qui peut
faire le tour. D'ailleurs, quand vous
regardez la vidéo de du discours de
Poutine, vous voyez que vous allez
l'Amérique du Sud et vous avez le truc
qui fait le tour comme ça. C'est
effrayant. Dites-vous bien la chose
suivante, c'est que le traité anti
balistique missile américain
ABM
ABM le traité ABM bah le traité ABM
prenez une map monde hein. Vous avez
l'Amérique, vous avez la Russie mais le
chemin le plus court ça passe par le
pôle. Donc tout le système de protection
russe américain, c'est dans l'Amérique
du Nord, c'est en Alaska. Vous voyez des
coins comme ça. Et les Russes peuvent
les attaquer en gros poil. Il va falloir
mettre la même chose au Mexique. C'est
pas possible. Non mais c'est moi j'ai
trouvé j'ai trouvé ça extrêmement
amusant d'ailleurs vous avez pas vu
quand Poutine fait son discours, il dit
et ça n'est pas tout. Il ressent un
deuxème truc. Alors déjà le missile
supers sonque il y a des gens qui
écrivent oui ça marche pas non ça marche
il aucun problème. Enfin ça marchait en
on est quand même pas plus con que ces
gens-là. Donc au une nouvelle
d'aujourd'hui euh ils viennent
d'annoncer que ils investiraient 1
milliard de plus
pour la recherche sur les nouvelles
armes.
Qui ça ?
Le gouvernement russe.
Bon bah oui, vous savez c'est pas
beaucoup par rapport à l'UR au budget.
Alors première chose, il y a ça. Ensuite
il parle d'un drone sous-marin. Vous
avez vu ? Alors ce drone sous-marin,
c'est pareil. Vous avez un réacteur puis
là-dedans, une fois que vous l'avez
amorcé, il va cracher de la
radioactivité. C'est une arme. Donc ce
trucl va se propulser.
Et moi, j'explique ça à fond la caisse
dans cette deuxième vidéo en anglais. Je
me suis dit bon, tant qu'à faire,
puisqu'il y a ce prétex, je vais
expliquer aux gens pour qu'ils
comprennent bien ce que c'est que la
MHD. Donc j'ai expliqué tout ça. Alors,
il y a un truc par exemple, c'est que
quand vous prenez les torpilles, hein,
pendant la seconde guerre,
le cheval, c'est ça ?
Ah oui, mais oui, le avant le cheval.
Second
cheval cheval.
Seconde Guerre mondiale, vitesse des
torpilles, 75 km/h. Vous
prenez sa petite montre. Ah oui, vous
prenez votre monde, vous lâchez la
torpille, il y en a pour 2 minutes avant
qu'elle fasse mouchement. Maintenant,
les torpilles hélicisses, elles font 100
km/h. 120 c'est le maximum. Pourquoi ça
peut pas aller plus vite ? Parce que
l'eau ça frotte terrible. Vous prenez
votre canne, vous faites comme ça dans
l'air, puis vous faites ça comme ça dans
l'eau, bah c'est plus pareil. L'eau,
elle est 1000 fois plus dense que l'air.
Donc on a un problème de traîner pas
possible. Si vous dites à quelqu'un,
"Vriez pas me faire une torpille qui à
300 kmh, c'est pas possible, ça frotte
trop."
Alors à ce point-là et ben il faudra
enlever le frottement. C'est là moi je
trouve ça génial la torphil chal c'est
génial. Qu'est-ce comence comment
comment ce que les Russes font ? Ils ont
un générateur de gaz à l'avant qui
vaporise l'eau et hop la torpie est
entouvrée de de vapeur. D'ailleurs, une
couche assez épaisse, ça doit faire 50
cm. Elle se promène dans la vapeur
d'eau. Et à quelle vitesse ? 500 km/h.
Alors dites-vous bien la chose suivante,
c'est que cette torpille russe, elle est
elle équipait les sous-marus en 1977. il
y a 50 ans hein.
Voilà. Alors déjà les torpilles. Alors
quelles sont vos sources ?
Quoi ?
Quelles sont vos sources ?
Mais allez dans internet vous c'est tout
le monde le sait mes sources tout le
monde le sait. Cette torpique cheval
vous la voyez dans des foires
exposition, vous avez pas vu les photos.
Alors faut voir un peu comment ça se
pilote. C'est génial. Vous avez le
générateur de gaz à l'avant et puis vous
avez deux petites biellettes. Alors ça
envoie le gaz un peu plus à droite, un
peu plus à gauche. C'est un truc
vachement vachement agile. Et c'est
piloté. C'est philo guidé. Vous savez ce
que c'est le philo au guidage ? La
torpille sort puis il y a deux tiges qui
se baladent comme ça avec un fil et hop,
on pilote la torpille.
Mes sources mes sources tout le monde le
sait.
C'est qui tout le monde ?
Quoi ?
C'est qui tout le monde ? Mais allez
voir sur internet, vous allez voir tous
les rapports. Par exemple, c'est comme
vous me dites par exemple c'est ce ce
missile américain, quels sont vos
sources, vous avez les rapport
déclassifié, vous les trouverez, les
photocopies, il y a même tous les
calculs, tous les détails, tous les
plans. Alors voilà, c'est quand même des
sources qui sont fiables. Alors
franchement, alors si ce qui est
amusant, c'est que je sais pas si les
Français ont compris que les torpilles à
poud'était quand même plus rapide. Je me
rappelle un jour, il y avait une
manifestation à Paris qui s'appelait
Euronaval. Et j'avais un copain qui
était cette manifestation, ça remonte à
10 ans et il avait parlé de cette
éventualité des torpilles hyper véloces
et un amiral lui avait dit "Vous savez
en matière de torpille la vitesse ce
n'est pas tout. Bien sûr 100 km/h contre
500 voyez 500 kmh. Alors après je vais
en 2000 à un collocque étrange à
Brighton.
Et là quand j'arrive à ce colloque sur
la propulsion avancée,
disons que c'est organisé par un
ingénieur de Brighton. On verra le
colloque de Brighton juste après. On va
finir les armes russes. C'est c'est
connecté. Alors on vous écoute.
C'est les armes russes ça. Quand
j'arrive là-bas, je tombe sur un type
qui s'appelait Allan Holz qui
travaillait pour Carglil. Il me dit
"Vous êtes Jean-Pierre Petit ?" Je dis
"Oui, je crois."
Et il me dit "Je vous connais depuis
1976."
Comment ? Bah, on va donner vos notes au
contre-endu de MHD analyser. Et à ce
moment, on se met à parler et je dis
mais vous touchez bien votre bille de ce
côté-là. Moi, je croyais que la MHD
avait été abandonnée un peu partout mais
pas du tout. Sur le plan militaire, on a
continué mis en tête et il me dit
"J'étais chargé de la mise au point de
la torpille MHD américaine." Ah, je je
me contente de vous donner mon
témoignage, ce que j'ai entendu, quoi.
Bon, et euh je lui dis "Comment ça
marche ?"
Il me dit "Mais comme dans votre bande
dessinée, le mur du silence". Ah oui, il
y a pas de problème. Alors après,
je dit "Mais à quelle vitesse ça pouvait
aller ?" Moi j'avais pensé 500 km/h et
là je me rappellerai toute ma vie, il il
m'a regardé avec un l'air là en disant
"Oh mchement avec mon vous y êtes pas du
tout." Ah bon ? me permett d'ouvrir une
parenthèse. Est-ce que vous pensez que
vous avez subi une ops des États-Unis
pour vous faire passer pour un crétin
allumé pour que la France et les
l'Europe abandonne ses recherches sur la
MHD ?
Moi, je pense que on n' pas besoin de
citer les Français à faire des choses
comme ça. Ils le font tout seul. C'est
pas la peine qu'il y ait une
intervention américaine.
Je dis une intervention américaine sur
votre propre personne puisque vous étiez
la pointe de diamant sur ses recherches
et que votre parcours un petit peu
sulfureux.
Mais pourquoi c'est sulfureux ? Je
comprends pas ce mot. Ça veut dire quoi
sulfureux ? Moi je sens pas le souffle.
Vous savez, j'ai enlevé mes chaussures,
j'ai pas les pieds fourchus.
Franchement, je peux vous les montrer,
hein.
Non mais ça veut dire quoi sulfureux ?
C'est quoi sulfureux ? Justement, vous
voyez votre pensée,
c'est pas ma pensée. Quand on quand on
prononce vous qui dites que je suis
quand on prononce le mot Jean-Pierre
Petit, les scientifiques tournent les
talons.
Tourn les talons. Alors oui, tout à
l'heure, on parlait de blocage mais
regardez, dès qu'on s'aventure un petit
peu à droite, un petit peu à gauche, ah
c'est sulféré. Voilà la image D c'est
sur le fureux hein. Non
2000 km/h sous l'eau. Mon dieu c'est de
la folie. C'est
ça. On parle pas de la MHD là on parle
du fait que vous ayez reçu des papiers
des petits hommes verts qui vous
expliquaient la nature de la vie et de
la nature de l'univers et que à la fin
vous êtes passé pour un gogo, un pigeon.
Je vais passer pour un pigeon.
Ce qui a enterré ce qui a enterré la MHD
définitivement.
Oh, elle s'enter toute seule, il y a pas
de problème. Non, non, vous savez la la
façon dont la recherche a été menée en
France, mais c'est à ce
J'ai emplois une expression peut-être
assez vulgaire, mais elle me paraissait
bien vu. C'est à se poignarder le cul
avec des saucisses. Voilà. Et moi, c'est
comme ça que je vois les choses. Ah
franchement, mais vous n'imaginez pas
mais qui est-ce qui prend les décisions
? C'est regardez, moi j'étais dans mon
petit laboratoire de mécanique des
flutes de Marseille. J'avais réussi à
supprimer l'instabilité de Vilikov et à
ce moment-là on abandonne toute la MHD
et moi j'étais là en disant non dodo,
j'ai fait un truc qui marche maisant le
bateau coulait, ça avait été décidé par
des énarques. Vous savez la la France
est dirigée par les polytechniciens.
C'est effrayant. Il y a des gens qui n'y
connaissent rien, qui prennent des
décisions.
C'est pareil. Alors on pourra parler du
nucléaire là, on est en plein dedans.
Quelle catastrophe. Alors, s'agissant de
la MHD, mais on n' pas eu besoin d'une
pression américaine pour abandonner ça.
La connerie en France, c'est une valeur
sûre et on n pas besoin de la stimuler.
Elle s'autostimule toute seule, il y a
pas de problème. Vous savez, d'ailleurs,
il y a une chose, c'est que si c'est
nouveau, les gens diront "ça a pas été
fait ailleurs." C'est c'est inquiétant,
quoi. Mais vous savez, au CNRS, je me
rappelle, il y avait un type qui était
déjà directeur d'un d'un observatoire,
il est venu me trouver. Oui, il m'a dit
"Ton onde choc, faut bien que tu la
retrouves quelque part." Alors, je dit
"Mais est-ce que tu pourrais me trouver
un argument scientifique là-dedans ?"
Oui, je t'enverrai ça. Puis vraiment, ah
oui, je me rappelle, je sortais de mon
accident de travail à l'époque, j'avais
des béquilles, hein, j'étais pas bien.
Et il me dit "Tu sais, je vais te dire
un petit peu ce que la commission
souhaite. Je vais peut-être te choquer,
mais écoutez bien ce que je vais vous
dire parce que c'est ça la recherche
française. On veut que tu épluches des
patates. Tu te prends une petite
galaxie, un petit cliché, tu fais un
petit calcul pas terrible et tout
rentrera dans l'ordre. soit médiocre et
ça ira bien. Rendez compte, c'est comme
ça.
Revenons aux armes russes.
Revenons aux armes russes. Alors déjà,
on a parlé du missile de croisière
supersonique à production nucléaire. Bon
ça je pense que tout le monde sera
d'accord. Ça tient debout. Alors ensuite
le le missile sous-marin des Russes.
Alors vous avez vu ce que dit Poutine ?
rapide, ça c'est deux petites tailles,
ça va vachement vite. La portée est
illimitée. Alors, il y a un truc, c'est
que quand vous avez un
un drone sous-marin comme ça, vous allez
pas lui mettre une bombe de 300 kn, vous
allez dire "Allez allons-y carrément, on
va mettre 300 m tonnes." Vous avez vu la
la tsar bomba russe, vous rappelez ?
C'était énorme truc, c'était 100 mnes.
C'est un machin qui devait paiser 20
tonnes. Il fallait un bombardier be pour
le porter. Mais quand vous êtes dans un
sous-marin, vous avez Archimède qui vous
porte. Alors, allons-y. Mettons une
bombe de 100, 200, 300 mn. Vous allez
faire exploser ça devant San Francisco,
vous faites un tsunami de 300 m de haut.
Vous imaginez ? Alors, il y a des gens
qui disent "Vous rendez compte, c'est
c'est russe, c'est monstrueux mais il
faut que le nucléaire soit monstrueux."
C'est la seule façon qu'on s'en serve
pas. Ce qui était pharant, c'est de voir
qu'il y a des bombes stratégiques. Je me
rappelle, j'avais un copain dont le
frère était spécialiste en bombes de
théâtre.
Alors, on fait pas exposer des bonnes
momes dans les théâtres, c'est le
théâtre d'opération. Donc, à ce
moment-là, dans à l'institut de vous
étud de la défense nationale, qu'est-ce
que vous suggérez ? Ben, une petite
bombe de temps, une petite bombe des
bombes de théâtre. Mais le nucléaire
même, ils se rendent pas compte même les
petites bombes de 300 m, mais c'est déjà
20 fois Hiroshima.
300 kg.
300 Konn. Oui, 300, c'est 20 fois
Hiroshima. Mais ça fait rien, c'est des
bombes stratégiques.
Je crois que les stratèges comme ça qui
envisagent que le nucléaire puisse être
appliqué dans dans les guerres, c'est
pas possible. Ils savent même pas de
quoi ils parlent. Sans blague.
Voilà,
il y avait que ça dans la vidéo de
Poutine.
Non. Alors donc le drone sous-marin
après il est parti sur autre chose.
Bon c'est sûr qu'au début j'en ai pas
parlé mais il a commencé par développer
Sarmat. Sarmat c'est un missile de 200
tonnes. Une fusée. Alors vous avez la
chose suivante, vous avez la sphère
terrestre et puis quand les Russes
attaquent les Américains, hop, ils
passent par le volont nord avec une
belle trajectoire parabolique. Alors il
y a une autre solution, c'est de passer
par le pôle sud seulement finalement il
faut une puissance beaucoup plus
considérable. Donc ils ont fait qu'ils
ont assuré le coup en faisant ce truc
là. On sait faire des fusées énormes.
Bon, ils ont fait une fusée de 200
tonnes. Un gros machin. Bon, c'est un
gros pétard. Alors, après le missile
supersonique, après le missile
sous-marin, alors on passe à Kinjal.
Kinjal. Mais faut vous dire une chose,
c'est que les vidéos qui sont dans le
truc, c'est bidon, hein. D'ailleurs, un
moment Poutine le dit, on vous a pas
montré les véritables images parce que
comprenez qu'il y a un petit côté secret
défense. Bon, simplement, on a montré un
Mig 31 avec un truc en dessous. puis ça
s'allume et tout ça. Bon, c'est ce
Michel Kinjal, mais il faut voir le
chiffre qui est donné, c'est MAC 10.
Alors, MACD 10, ça veut dire que les
Russes ont pris pied dans l'hypersonique
et maintenant dans tous les pays du
monde
développé, que ce soit les Français, les
Anglais, les Américains, les Allemands,
il va falloir avoir de l'hypersonique.
L'hypersonique, ça commence à Mac 5. Mac
35, c'est déjà c'est du haut supersonic.
Mais euh à partir de Max, alors vous
avez un truc, c'est que assez haut
nombre de Mac, le frottement de l'air
crée une élévation de température.
Alors, donnons un chiffre. Prenez
Concorde. Bah, quand Concorde volait, la
température parétale montait de 100°.
Quand l'avion se posait, il était à
100°, on pouvait se brûler. Maintenant,
vous avez le SR71 là, le l'avion espion
américain, c'est 400. Il volait à Mac
32. Vous imaginez le truc qui se pose,
il est à 400°. Alors, il y a un truc
marrant d'ailleurs, c'est que quand même
là-dedans, il y a un pilote, il faut pas
qu'il soit à 400°. Donc, on utilise le
carburant comme réfrigérant et lui, on
le réfrigère avec sa combinaison mais
pas la la cabine, il fait il y a 70°
dans la cabine. Et alors les vitres,
elles sont à 400°. Et vous verrez, vous
trouverez ça comme anecdote dans
internet. Quand le type fait un vol de
longue durée, s'il a un un croque
monsieur à manger, il le sort de et il
le met contre la fenêtre pour pour le
rechauffer. Voyez 400°. Et ça c'est Mac
32.
Il a pas une combinaison pressurisée ?
Non.
Si. Si mais
non mais il a une circulation d'air,
c'est pas le problème. Mais la
température quand il enlève ses gants
pour bouffer, il est dedans de l'air à
70°
et toutes les appariats sont à 400. Je
sais pas si vous imaginez les les
tubulures, les pompes, c'est quand même
énorme. Et ça n'est que Mac 32. Alors
vous augmentez Mac 4, Mac 5, ça devient
énorme. Alors Mac 10, on comprend pas.
Alors justement dans cette vidéo en
anglais, j'ai essayé posément de donner
aux gens une possibilité de se faire
eux-mêmes leur propre opinion. Parce que
vous avez un truc par exemple, c'est que
la température d'arrêt, elle varie comme
le carré du nombre de Mac. Donc si on
arrive actuellement à faire des missiles
à Mac 5, si on fait ça à Mac 10, ça veut
dire que la température est quatre fois
plus forte. Vous arrivez à des trucs qui
font 6 7 10000°gr.
Donc la MHD
bah donc quelque chose. Donc quelque
chose. Et c'est quelque chose ça peut
être que la MHD. Voilà. Alors j'explique
comment ça marche.
On vous écoute.
Comment ça marche. Il faut de
l'électricité. Et par exemple pour le
missile kinjal, c'est pareil pour la
torpille MHD. La torpille MHD tout à
l'heure on l'a évoqué comme ça
rapidement ce projet. Comment on fait
pour faire aller une une torpille à des
milliers de kilomètres ? Bah il faut
supprimer le frottement. Alors supprimer
de frottement alors si vous voulez c'est
un truc marrant ça, j'ai montré ça dans
ces vidéos, c'est que finalement le gars
qui a inventé ça c'est Stewart Way qui
est un américain. Il a inventé ça en
1961 quelque chose comme ça. C'est un
propulseur pariétal. Alors a construit
un sous-marin qui faisait 3 m de long
avec ce propulseur et il arrivait à le
faire aller à 40 cm secondes en aspirant
l'eau comme ça. Donc ça a été montré à
des gens, ils ont ils ont pas trouvé ça
intéressant. Ben oui, tout ce qu'il
avait comme source d'énergie, c'est des
batteries. Donc le champ magnétique 150
gosses, il aurait fallu 10 Tesla. La
propulsion marine, c'est le chiffre créé
c'est 10 Tesla. Donc il fallait le
supraconducteur. Mais quand vous
regardez le brevet de,
il met des fils avec de l'hélium. Il a
déjà pensé la supraconduction. Mais vous
voyez ça c'est l'exemple du type qui est
visionnaire, il explique son truc, tout
le monde s'en fout. Tout le monde est
passé à côté. Vous savez, c'est arrivé à
un type extraordinaire, c'est Tesla. He
on parle de Tesla. C'est vrai que c'est
un inventeur extraordinaire. et Tesla a
inventé la première torpille téléguidée.
Alors, la torpille de Tesla, ça
ressemble à une baignoire, hein, et à
l'intérieur, il y a des batteries, une
petite hélice et cetera avec un
couvercle. Alors, elle est pas en
plongée, mais disons que si vraiment
c'est au rat de l'eau, on voit rien
quoi. Bon, personne le dessus, il y a
des antennes et quand il invente ça,
mais la radio n'existe encore pas.
Autrement dit, en faisant des étincelles
électriques, son antenne reçoit. Vous
savez, c'est comme ça qu'on a inventé
les ondes radio, qu'on a découvert les
zes électromagnétiques. On s'est aperçu
que quand on faisait des décharges comme
ça dans la pièce à côté, il se passait
quelque chose. Donc Tesla imaginait et
puis il envoyait des impulsions comme ça
et puis il avait un truc qui se
déplaçait. Alors ça c'était Tribor Babor
neutre, Tribor Babor neutre. Donc un
petit coup à Tribor, un petit coup à
Babord. Donc il prend sa baignoire et
dans un est comme ça où il y a un bateau
à l'encre, il montre au militaire que
bom il arrive, il fait arriver le truc
tout contre. Ils ont rien compris. Faut
imaginer ce que c'est qu'un truc pareil.
Vous mettez ce machin à l'eau et en 2
jours de nuit, vous l'amenez contre un
bateau. Mais c'est une torpie et guidée.
Les gens ont rien compris. Et voilà
Tesla. Regardez Kanda avec son avion
supersonicque avec son avion à réaction
1909 au salon de l'aviation. Allez voir
sur internet, vous découvrez les photos.
Il y a des gens, ils se trompent
d'époque. Et là Steve Wartway 1961
propulsur MHD, personne comprend rien.
Voilà.
Alors après ben on prend ce trucl puis
on le développe. Alors il y a une chose
curieuse c'est que
quand on prend la torbique cheval par
exemple bon elle a un propulseur fusé et
si on n pas un système qui l'entoure de
vapeur mais il faudrait une énergie
monstrueuse pour arriver à la faire
aller à 500 km/h or avec cette jet de
gaz à l'avant ça supprime tout. Bon là
c'est pareil avec un peu d'électricité,
on va supprimer le frottement et en
avant la torpille cabale. Alors d'où
vient l'électricité ? Et ben, dans la
tuyère, vous avez un générateur MHD, un
générateur à autoxitation.
Là, là, on était dans les missiles, pas
dans les torpilles.
C'est pareil.
Poutine.
Le missile Kinjal, il a aussi c'est la
même chose. Le missile Kinjal, c'est
l'équivalent de la torpille MHD mais
aérien. Il faut bien la créer quelque
part. l'électricité, c'est pas des des
batteries que vous allez mettre dans
votre missile. Alors, vous avez une
cuillère et puis vous avez un bobinage
qui crée un champ magnétique. Dans la
poudre, vous mettez du césium, ça sort à
3000° et je vous assure que ça crache.
Alors, on pourrait dire "Mais comment
savez-vous ça ?" Bon bah là encore faut
chercher. Disons qu'en dans les années
80, je suis allé à un colloc aux
États-Unis
et euh j'ai discuté avec des Russes.
J'ai l'air très bavard comme ça mais
quand je veux faire parler quelqu'un, je
suis redoutable. Oui. Et alors j'ai
interviewé ces Russes et j'ai découvert
les générateurs de Pavlovski. Alors vous
vous les trouverez sur internet. Il y a
même des films de ce truc-là. Euh c'est
présenté avec les armes sismiques.
Donc les armes sismiques, il faut un
générateur électrique qui vous crache 10
20 30 MW pendant 30 40 secondes. Comment
on fait un truc pareil ? Bah regardez
les photos. Vous avez trois fusées à
poudre 70 cm de diamètre, 3 m de long
qui crache comme ça et puis vous avez
des gros bobinage et c'est un truc à
autoexcitation au sens vous créez votre
champ magnétique, vous créez peut-être
1000 2000 gos et ça crée le courant et
le courant crée le champ. Donc à ce
momentl ça va monter je ne sais pas à
combien de Tesla mais il y a un truc
c'est que la puissance est considérable.
Donc par conséquent dans cette tuyère
vous avez une puissance électrique mais
donc pour le le missile kinja c'est
peut-être 10 MW et vous envoyez ça à
l'avant et en avant vous supprimez
l'onde de choc vous supprimez la la
traînée et ça encore c'est du délire
technologique. Et vous savez les Russes
c'est les champions de la MHD et vous
savez qui est-ce qui a été le génie de
la MHD en Russie ? C'est Sacarofon.
Il a fait des trucs fantastiques dans
les années 50. Il a surtout la MHD
explosive. Sakerov produisait 100
millions d'ampères avec un truc qui
était gros comme ça. Ah mais il y a moi
j'adore chez les Russes.
Sont vos sources
quoi.
Vos sources
mais c'est partout. Regardez, il y en a
c'est publié mes sources. Enfin bon,
j'ai des articles dans mon site qui
expliquent tout ça, mais ça n'a rien de
mystérieux,
je vous assure. Si ça n'a rien
mystérieux, pourquoi nous en France on a
des torpilles
toutes pouraves ?
Je voulais vous répondre grossièrement,
c'est parce qu'on est con, c'est tout.
C'est pas possible.
C'est pas possible. Moi je quand j'ai
quand j'ai fait ce trucl sur les
l'histoire du cours qui parlp hyper
véloce, ils ont pas réagi.
Actuellement ma ma vidéo d'une heure sur
les armes russes, ça a créé une panique
dans les hautes sphères militaires. Il y
a sans doute un chef d'étatmajor qui a
dit "Dites-moi cet MHD là, nous avons
quelque chose là-dessus ?" Ah oui, en
général, nous y travaillons. Nous y
travaillons. Si vous cherchez la MSD
française, vous trouverez un catamaran
en polystyrène avec un petit moteur à
aimant. C'est au niveau du DEA, quoi.
Disons que s'il y a des recherches qui
sont faites, c'est carrément au niveau
de ce que je faisais il y a 50 ans. Les
les les ingénieurs militaires sont pas
venus vous voir pour avoir des petites
infos.
les les mecs de chez MBDA avec leur
centrale inercielle pour pour petit
planeur.
Écoutez, j'ai raconté ça dans des
bouquins, mais comment vous dire ? Euh
il y a une chose qu'il est terrifiée,
c'est que vous savez, on a cette
expression anglo-saxonne, sortir le chat
du sac, hein. Vous savez quand on sort
un chat d'un sac, le rentrer après,
c'est extrêmement compliqué. Il y a pas
moyen. Donc par conséquent, qu'est-ce
que moi je proposais là-dedans ? Je vous
ai expliqué que quand j'avais mon espèce
de générateur MHD en forme de canon,
bom, j'avais fabriqué une onde de choc.
Donc à ce moment-là, j'ai repris tout ça
en disant voilà, on va utiliser ça comme
soufflerie supersonique. On va avoir un
courant d'argon à 10000°. On va mettre
un profil dedans et puis première photo
crioscopie, on voit les ondes de choc
puis ensuite pof, on branche plus d'onde
de choc. Je vous assure, c'est comme ça
que ça serait passé. J'ai un type que
j'ai mis en teste doctorat là-dessus. On
a fait du publication. Euh,
comment il s'appelle ?
Euh, Bertrand Lebin. Un gars, il est
venu me trouver, il m'a dit "Oh, j'ai
fait les ans et métiers. Euh, je
voudrais faire une thèse avec vous." Je
dis "Écoutez, si vous voulez les
emmerdements, c'est garanti. Il m'a dit
"Je m'en fous, j'ai envie de m'amuser."
Bon, il a envie de s'amuser. Donc, on a
fait des trucs comme ça. Oh mon dieu,
mais on va sombrer dans l'anecdote, vous
n'imaginez pas ce qu'on a connu. Donc,
il a fait ce truclà. Euh par exemple, un
moment, on a une une communication, une
publication au genre de mécanique
français de haut niveau et tout ça. Bon
et euh
on a fait des calculs sur ordinateur.
Vous savez ce qu'on avait comme
ordinateur ? le petit Mintosch comme ça.
Et je me rappelle un jour, je rencontre
Barnous qui était directeur du
département sciences physiques de
l'ingénieur et je lui explique qu'on a
obtenu ses résultats le calcul de
mécanique des fluides d'extinateur. Il
m'a dit ça n'est pas possible, on ne
peut pas faire des calculs de genre avec
cette brouette. Je dis non mais on en
avait pas un, on en avait cinq.
C'est-à-dire que le bras avait une moto
et on mettait les calculs dans cinq bing
toch. Il passait le matin pour les
récupérer. On a fait un truc
multiprocesseur avant la lettre. Ça
datait des années 80 quoi, avec une
moto.
Voilà. Bon, alors on a fait ça et je me
rappelle euh il y a une communication
qui a été adoptée euh acceptée en 1987
au colloque de Tsukuba au Japon.
Alors moi, j'ai dit au CNRS euh il
faudrait que j'aille au colloque de
Tsukuba. Et alors une secrétaire me
répond vous accorde 4000 francs. Je sais
plus combien ça fait en euros. Enfin
voyez, vous faites la conversion et
c'était le prix du billet avion. Alors,
j'ai dit mais c'est embêtant parce que
il y a le billet d'avion mais il y a
aussi l'hôtel, la bouffe et tout ça,
l'inscription colloque. Ah mais monsieur
qu'est-ce que vous décidez ? Al
finalement j'ai dit écoutez voilà j'ai
trouvé un dériveur d'occasion. J'ai
acheté des boîtes de rondron en passant
par le canal de Suè en 3 mois je dois
pouvoir y arriver et je me ferai
rapatrier par le consulat. Enfin c'est
absurde donner 4000 francs pour aller à
Colloc au Japon. Ça n'a pas de sens.
Combien combien ça gagne un ex du CNRS
comme vous en retraite ?
Je sais plus. 2000 €ou quelque chose
comme ça. 2000 ou ça doit être ça ou un
peu plus de 2000 €. Ouais pourquoi ? Al
oui ben écoutez c'est pas vous prenez un
ingénieur vous divisez par deux c'est ça
le salaire du chercheur c'est la moitié
de l'ingénieur mo j'ai fait superhéros
tous mes copain ben ça leur double de
moins.
alors vous voyez le colloc de après il y
a eu le colloque de Pékin mais j'ai pas
pu y aller pas d'argent alors déjà
puis alors vous savez il y a un truc
écoutez euh j'ai un dossier CNRS qui est
pay comme ça c'est dommage quand je suis
parti à la retraite j'aurais dû le
photocopier si j'avais plus la
possibilité j'aurais fait un DVD ou un
CD simplement pour que les gens puissent
lire ça mais j'ai passé 10 ans à faire
des projets à à 10 briqu à deux briques,
à 1000 balles
rien. Même une année, j'ai envoyé un
report CNRS, il y a pas eu d'écho. Il y
avait mon personnage de BD, l'enturlu
qui est en train de pisser dans un
violon et j'ai mis chercheur en train de
faire son rapport d'activité. Ils l'ont
pas protesté. Non, parce que c'est un
scandale. Je veux dire, vous iriez
explorer mon mon dossier, c'est fou
quoi. Et même, il y a un truc, un jour
un type arrive à l'obson de Marseille et
il a mon dossier CRS. Alors, j'ai plus
de consulter et tout d'un coup
le nom du type
le gars bah c'était un chercheur, je me
rappelle plus mais il était venu avec
mon dossier, on lui avait demandé de
faire
pourquoi ? Mais parce que chaque année
quand on doit faire un rapport sur
quelqu'un, on lui passe son dossier. On
a le dossier du mec comme ça il peut
regarder un peu tout ça. Et en fuitant
le dossier, je tombe sur un échange de
courrier entre euh la section du CNRS et
un chercheur étranger et je vois la
réponse du gars et euh le type dit quit
la question
quoi ?
Quelle était la question ? Bah, on avait
pas la question mais on avait les
réponses et au bout du mois, j'ai
peut-être pas trouvé la lettre qui
posait les questions, mais les réponses
c'était bon, ce chercheur
a travaillé dans un une gamme de domaine
assez vaste comme ça. C'est vrai que
j'ai fait de la topologie, retour au
monde de la sphère, plein de trucs.
à propos de la imag disait
testif
normalent
traduction je ne vois rien d'étrange
là-dedans. Je peux vous assurer que ce
type est dans un état mental normal.
Autrement dit, qu'est-ce qu'a fait le
CRS ? Un type qui veut faire disparaître
de choc, il doit pas être bien. Il faut
demander est-ce qu'il a un grain ? Donc
c'est quoi ? Quand vous dites il est
fêé, c'est vrai le CNRS a pensé que
j'étais fêé. Faire disparaître les ondes
de choc, faut être fêé. Euh avoir une
vitesse de la lumière numéro 2, faut
être fêé. Mais il faut dès que vous
faites un pat,
vous êtes fêé. Euh
vous avez fait des beaucoup de pas à
côté de la route.
Bien sûr, bien sûr. Beaucoup de pas.
Bon, revenons aux armes russes.
Alors, les armes russes, donc le missile
kinjal, c'est l'équivalent du truc
sous-marin avec une tuyère qui sert de
générateur. Alors, à ce moment-là,
d'ailleurs, si vous allez sur internet,
vous allez commencer à trouver ce trucl,
il y a même des thèses là-dessus. On va
appeler ça MHD bypass. MHD bypass.
Bypass, vous savez, c'est quand on se
transfère quelque chose de là à là.
Alors, quand je prends un turbéacteur,
ben dans le tumbo réacteur, on pourrait
dire que c'est méchanical bypass.
Mecanical bypass, pourquoi ? Bah parce
que vous avez de l'énergie qui est
prélevée par une turbine et qui est
envoyé au compresseur. Donc vous prenez
de l'énergie à l'arrière, vous la mettez
à l'avant. Bah, c'est pareil. Là, vous
avez une cuillère à l'arrière qui
transforme une partie d'énergie en
électricité qui la renvoie à l'avant.
Alors, on commence à voir ce thème de MB
MHD bypass.
Il bluffe Poutine ou pas
quoi ?
Il bluffe Poutine ou pas ?
Pas du tout. Pas du tout. Il écoutez, il
pourrait pas se payer luxe, c'est pas
possible. Alors le truc donc vous avez
ce truclà mais c'est pas fini comme
dirait Poutine. Et ça n'est pas fini. Je
trouve ça marrant. Vous avez le comment
ça s'appelle ?
Le missile avant-garde. Alors avantgarde
mais ça fait 2,50 de long, c'est tout
petit. Avant-garde, c'est un planeur
hypersénique.
Autrement dit, vous avez la fusée
Sarmat qui emmène 24 petits planeurs
avant-garde.
Et ces planeurs avant-garde, c'est des
trucs qui sont lâchés à MAC 20 dans la
haute atmosphère et qui se promènent
comme ça. Et c'est pas du tout, vous
voyez, on parle de missile pilotable en
phase de rentrée. Alors, pilotable en
phase de rentrée, un truc qui rentre
dans l'atmosphère, un petit coup à
droite, un petit coup à gauche. C'est
juste pour s'adapter la non tandis que
le machin avantgarde, ça fait vraiment
des grands virages. Alors, comment ça
marche ? Et ben là, vous avez fait du
planeur, non ? Oui, hein. Alors, comment
ça marche un planeur ? Avec la gravité
hein. On se sert du poids, on descend et
puis ma fois avec ça, on fabrique de
l'énergie cinétique puis on vole. Mais
c'est pareil le truc se balade comme ça
avec à MAC 20, il fabrique
l'électricité. avec électricité, il peut
d'une part négocier son histoire de choc
en la faisant disparaître, négocier le
frottement et puis piloter. Vous assure
que les gouvernes MHD, c'est infiniment
plus efficace que les gouvernes
aérodynamiques.
Les les les torpilles MHD, ça fait comme
ça. C'est pour ça que dans son dans son
discours, vous noterez que Poutine à
chaque fois il dit une grande
manœuvrabilité.
C'est vraiment des trucs mais sa c'est
très important. Par exemple, vous avez
un truc tout d'un coup, il y a un
missile antimissile qui vous arrive
dessus mais le machin les vite, c'est
encore problème parce que le missile qui
arrive dessus, il est pas capable de
prendre des virages comme ça. Voilà.
Donc ce petit machin, moi je sais
comment ça marche ça. Je vais aborder ça
dans cette fin de vidéo. Je vais tout
expliquer.
Ça va être marrant.
Bon, vous avez des choses à rajouter sur
les armes russes ? Non mais vous voyez
que enfin je sais pas mais je vais
encore passer pour quelqu'un de fêé. Je
dis que Poutine a raison que Mais vous
savez il y a un truc marrant.
Pourquoi il a raison ? Mais non, mais il
y a un truc marrant, c'est que c'est que
dans cette vidéo, j'ai numéroté mes
phrases. Ça va permettre de faire d'un
doublage. C'estàd que par exemple dans
cette vidéo, il y a 300 ou 400 phrases.
Bon, alors à ce momentlà, imaginez que
je veux doubler ça en russe. Je vais
demander à un russe de me faire une
bande audio avec phrase 47
et j'aurais plus faire du coup. Je ferai
une version russe comme ça les Russes
sauront comment marche le domicile.
Pourquoi il a raison Poutine ?
Bah il a raison parce que il le dit très
bien au départ. Les Américains sont
sortis vous savez le truc essentiel
c'est le 11 septembre. Le 11 septembre
ça a permis de faire n'importe quoi. Ça
permis à l'Amérique de se dire nous
sommes d'attaquer de toute part voilà
l'Iran, la Corée du Nord et cetera. Donc
à ce momentlà
eu des théories un peu fumeuses sur le
11 septembre. Bien sûr, bien sûr. Je
suis félé, vous savez très bien. Donc
j'ai des théories félé on va pas
rentrer.
Pas là pour juger
quoi.
N'est pas là pour juger.
Bon attendez changeons pas de sujet.
Pour le moment on était sur Poutine
Poutine Poutine sort dit l'Amérique sort
du traité ABM. Or ce ttré ABM c'est ça
qui garantissait la stratégie MAD
Mutuelle à destruction. Le fait que cet
équilibre de la terreur on a des bombes
épouvantables. Ne m'attaque pas parce
que moi je pourrais t'attaquer aussi.
Or, si tout d'un coup l'Amérique a de
quoi se protéger des missiles de
l'autre, c'est fini, c'est disymétrique.
Donc Poutine a commencé par dire il faut
reprendre ce ce traité ABM si vous
faites alors c'est là où c'est
merveilleux, vous trouverez facilement
sur le net une vidéo où Poutine efface
un journaliste, je sais pas d'où il sort
et les journalistes lui dit "Comment
réagissez-vous quand les gens disent que
ce traité ABM est dirigé contre l'Iran
À ce moment-là, il y a il y a Poutine
qui répond "Oh, écoutez, j'ai eu une
dure journée de travail, je suis assez
fatigué, mais je vais rentrer chez moi,
vous m'aurez bien fait rire." Non, c'est
merveilleux quoi. Vous voyez le traité à
BM, vous regardez tous les trucs
Amérique, ça rentre en sert complètement
la Russie. Mais non, non, mais c'est
comme par exemple dans ce traité ABM,
vous avez les armes spatiales, hein,
vous avez les trucs antisatellite
dans cette histoire là.
Les armes lasers,
les armes lasers. Exactement. Et ça ça
marche très bien. Même les Chinois ont
fait une petite démonstration là-dessus.
Et moi, je dirais que les Américains
diront à Poutine "Mais non, regardez ce
que dit Rean, les armes lasers, c'est
pas fait contre vos satellites, c'est
pour dégommer les soucoupes volantes."
Vous rappelez le baratin d'Oregan son
contre cette menace venue de l'espace.
Vous savez, on est dans un monde
complètement fou, hein.
Ouais. Alors donc Poutine a a créé de
nouveau, il a recréé la monstruosité.
C'est impossible à stopper. Comment
voulez-vous stopper un missile
sous-marin ? En plus ce truclà, si vous
allez à la villette, vous avez vu, il y
a un sous-marin qu'on peut visiter.
Il a créé la monstrueusité pour attaquer
ou pour défendre,
peu importe. Les armes sont
monstrueuses, hein. Il faut que les gens
sachent que c'est monstrueux et que ce
sera utilisé. C'est la fin du monde donc
on ne peut pas. Mais c'est comme ça,
vous savez. Il y a un truc, j'en parle
dans une de mes vidéos.
Pourquoi c'est la fin du monde ?
Mais c'est vraiment la fin du monde.
Regardez par exemple, entre la première
guerre mondiale et la deuxème guerre
mondiale, il s'est écoulé 21 ans, c'est
très court. Alors que c'était la derd,
vous savez, la première guerre mondiale,
x millions de morts, les tranchées.
Comment est-ce qu'a fait Hitler pour
réussir à convaincre les Allemands de
remettre ça 21 ans après ? Il leur a dit
"Mais c'est fini ça ? C'était la guerre
des tranchées. Moi j'ai inventé un truc,
c'est le blitz Creeg. Vous allez voir
avec assez peu de pair, on va gagner et
tout ça. Elle a fait un coup un coup la
Pologne, un coup la C'est pas comme ça
qu'il a convaincu les Allemands
quoi.
C'est pas comme ça qu'il a convaincu le
peuple allemand.
Bah pour bien sûr, mais il a déjà
convaincu qu'il était supérieur et
cetera. Et puis après
il est convaincu que le peuple allemand
avait le couteau sous la gorge parce
qu'il devait payer, qu'il y avait une
crise économique.
Oui, mais l'aspect militaire ça comptait
beaucoup un truc comme ça. Nous allons
nous allons gagner notre espace vital.
Nous avons raison. Nous allons faire
valoir les droits du peuple allemand, le
peuple allemand qui était là pour
dominer le monde, pour contrôler le
reste de la planète. Alors, les Anglais
sont pas laissés faire. Ah, ça a été un
petit peu embêtant. Puis après, il s'est
retourné vers la Russie, la catastrophe.
Vous connaissez l'histoire. Et quand il
était au fond de son bancaire à Berlin,
il aurait pu dire "Vous savez, je me
suis trompé. Finalement, le BFCK c'était
pas une bonne idée. On aurait Ah oui,
voilà." Et là, maintenant, vous avez
encore des gens qui sont là avec le leur
traité à BM. On dit "Mais quand est-ce
qu'ils arrêtent trop leurs conneries ?"
Comment on fait pour bousculer le milieu
scientifique français ?
Comment je fais
pour bousculer le milieu scientifique
français ?
Mais vous savez, dès qu'on prononce un
un mot,
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ? Qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire pour bousculer le
milieu scientifique français ?
Bah premièrement, il y a pas que la
France, hein.
On va rester sur la France là.
D'accord. Parce que moi je déjà moi je
travaille avec deux Matthus, il y en a
un qui est belge et l'autre qui est
canadien carrément. Et puis les les
échanges sont étroits. On a des projets
vachement intéressants, on en parlera
tout à l'heure. Donc les Français ma
fois
est-ce que c'est vraiment pas de la
perte de temps d'essayer de faire
travailler des Français ? Je sais pas
moi. Ça bouge pas. La France
elle est pas en marche.
Elle est pas en marche du tout là.
Franchement ça me fait rigoler. Non non
vous avez même prenez un type comme
Vilani. Bon ben, il nous a exponç
quoi ? qu'on a reçu.
Oui. Que vous avez reçu. Bah, vous
l'avez entendu dire par exemple que
l'enfouissement des déchets c'est la
moins mauvaise des solutions. Il y
connaît rien. Non mais on est on a un
monde de blabla de blabla. En marche,
c'est le blabla.
Pourquoi c'est pas la meilleure solution
l'enfouissement ?
Parce que c'est pas une solution du
tout. Il faut arrêter le nucléaire.
Écoutez, on fera une émission là.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Qu'est-ce qu'on
fait ? On fera une émission si on a si
on le décide.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les déchets
nucléaires ?
Bah, pour le moment, on les laisse en
place qu'on sait pas quoi en
C'est une catastrophe he on a un
réacteur nucléaire, on sait pas comment
le démanteler. Ben, on met une clôture
au dessous puis on laisse sur place.
C'est effrayant. Qu'est-ce que vous
voulez qu'on en foute de ces trucs là ?
Surtout pas refabriquer de nouveaux
trucs. Il y a une chose qui est
extraordinaire. Vous avez vu il y a eu
une émission, je crois que c'est sur la
5 sur le PR qui a fait un grand bruit
parce qu'on a expliqué que le PR, on est
en train de monter une cuve qui qui ne
correspond pas aux normes de résistance.
C'est passé de je sais pas 3 milliards à
il y a eu 7 milliards de dépassement.
Le PR est opérationnel en Chine là.
Mais oui, mais la question qu'on a pas
soulevé, qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un EPR ?
Vous le savez, je vais vous le dire. Le
PR, c'est le premier réacteur qui peut
marcher au plutonium.
Donc, recycler le plutonium militaire.
Bah regardez, nous avons fait euh une
usine qui s'appelle l'usine de l'ague,
hein. Et la l'usine de l'ague, on dit
"Amenez-nous nos vos au corps de
réacteur, ils arrivent avec des wagons
euh protégés et à ce momentlà les
Français conditionnent tout ça,
renvoient les déchets et on garde le
plutonium." Et alors, on est
milliardaire en plutonium. On a je sais
pas combien 60 tonnes de plutonium.
C'est formidable. Et à ce moment-là, les
éarques, les politiéticiens diront
"Comprenez ? Maintenant, nous avons une
ressource énergétique. Nous sommes
indépendants vis-à-vis de l'uranium.
Formidable. Mais c'est affreusement
dangereux le plutonium. Vous savez qu'il
a une durée de vie de 24000 ans. Si un
jour on a un accident nucléaire avec du
plutonium, c'est l'horreur absolue.
C'est l'irresponsabilité totale.
On en fait quoi les déchets ?
Mais on les laisse en place pour le
moment. On sait pas quoi en
Donc l'enfouissement non. Ah,
l'enfouissement c'est catastrophique.
Par exemple, ils qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
fait dans l'enfouissement ? Ils ont
cherché un filon d'argile. Un filon
d'argile. L'argile, c'est un truc qui
est hydraté, hein. Donc, il y a beaucoup
d'eau dans l'argile. Ensuite, on a créé
des galeries là-dedans. Puis alors, on a
Moi, j'ai bien étudié la question, je la
connais. On pourrait en parler. Je vous
donnerai tous les détails là-dessus.
Donc, comment est-ce qu'on descend les
charges, comment on les enfouit et
cetera. Maintenant, il y a une chose
terrible dans les mines, c'est
l'incendie. Et vous avez un truc par
exemple, c'est que quand on enfouit les
déchets, il y a pas que les cœurs de
réacteur, il y a toutes les matières
plastiques. Et les matière plastique, ça
se décompose en produision d'hydrogène.
Et l'hydrogène quand il y en a 5 % dans
l'air, ça s'enflamme. Alors, vous avez
un feu dans des galeries
et à ce moment-là, on sait pas gérer un
truc comme ça. Alors, on a envie de
ventiler. Donc, à ce moment-là, le site
de Bur, il y aurait des des comme ça. Et
on va ventiler. Et vous avez vu, on va
ventiler pendant un siècle. Si on arrête
de ventiler, c'est la catastrophe.
L'hydrogène va s'accumuler. On va avoir
des risques d'incendie. Mais est-ce que
vous croyez par exemple si on me disait
"Mais vous auriez pas une autre solution
à proposer ?" Ben je dis "Écoutez,
voilà, moi je suggérais la chose
suivante. On cherche un endroit où il y
a des falaises et puis on on fait des
galeries et puis on met les déchets
là-dedans mais de telle façon que ça se
ventile tout seul. Une ventilation
naturelle.
Toute façon, l'accès à ces falaises,
c'est comme l'accès dans les réacteurs.
Au moins, si on les met là-dedans,
peut-être qu'on sera plus protégé du
terrorisme parce que ça un sacré
problème. Prenez par exemple les les
cœurs comme ça qui sont dans les
piscines. Ah oui, c'est extraordinaire.
Vous avez donc à à l'ag et dans tous ces
endroits-là, des endroits où on stock
les les les cœurs usagers. Et ces
stockages, ils sont hors sol, ils sont
en hauteur. C'estd qu'autrement dit,
vous avez le cœur qui est dans la flotte
et là il y a une cloison. Vous tirez un
missile dans la cloison, ça fait un
trou, ça se vide et craque. Vous avez
vous avez le Fukujima,
hein. Il y a même des les écolos là,
comment ils s'appellent ? Green Peace.
Ils ont fait un truc en montrant que ils
peuvent s'approcher du truc. Alors,
c'est assez marrant. Ils se sont
approchés de cet endroit-là. Ils ont
tiré un feu d'artifice et vous avez les
deux gendarmes qui sont là mais ils sont
pas du bon côté, ils sont derrière la
cloison, derrière les barrières. Non
mais la
IT it ça vous parle
autre émission c'est très ça marchera
pas c'est tout. C'est c'est ça le défaut
c'est que ça marchera pas. Non mais
c'est compliqué. Écoutez, j'ai fait cinq
vidéos là-dessus. Elles sont en place
depuis 10 ans. Ces vidéos montrent que
tout ça ça tient pas debout et personne
n'a dit le contraire.
On va vous passer au tableau.
Ouais, on y va.
Doucement Jean-Pierre, doucement.
Voilà.
Alors,
je vous laisse.
Bon, alors ici, j'ai mis un petit
Qu'est-ce que vous allez qu'est-ce que
vous allez nous présenter ?
Bah, mes travaux d'astrophysique et de
cosmologie, hein. Hein ? Alors, c'estau
d'astrophysique et de cosmologie. Je
vous dis, il y a une date, il y a 3 qu
jours. 5è papier dans Astrophysique
Science à très beaucoup au butes
confirmations observationnelles qu'on a
pu obtenir. Alors là-dedans, comment ça
se quelles sont les grandes lignes de ce
modèle ? J'an je vais essayer
d'expliquer ça, c'est pas très commode.
Donc vous avez au départ ces thèmes de
la matière sombre et de l'énergie noire,
hein. Alors déjà, vous voyez le modèle
classique, vous savez, il y a une
matière mystérieuse, l'énergie
mystérieuse. Bon bah, qu'est-ce que
montre le modèle Janus ? C'est que cette
énergie sombre et cette matière sombre
s'est remplacée avantageusement par le
concept de masse négative. Alors,
d'autres diront "Mais la masse négative,
c'est pas possible que ça existe." Je
vous expliquerai pourquoi. Ensuite, ce
tru là, ça explique
le paradoxe de nonobservation de
l'antimatière cosmologique. Deuxème
point, ensuite vous avez les effets de
l'antigravitationnel qui sont expliqués,
le confinement des galaxies, les courbes
de rotation, la structure en d'échelle,
le great repeller, l'accélération de
l'expansion.
On prédit que l'antimatière qu'on va
fabriquer en laboratoire, elle tombera
bêtement vers le bas.
Bon voilà. Et puis alors ça c'est des
trucs publiés. C'est publié et selon les
critères de la communauté scientifique.
C'est donc publié et validé parce qu'à
partir moment où quelque chose est
publié et il y a personne qui écrit que
c'est de la connerie, c'est que ça doit
commencer à tenir un peu debout quoi.
Bon pu alors après, ben vous avez des
choses pas encore publiées. Les
fluctuations du du CMB, comment je
détermine la vitesse de la lumière dans
le deuxième feuillet, comment la
dissymétrie, le numérique et cetera et
cetera. Bon, alors maintenant, je sais
pas comment je vais m'y prendre.
D'abord, je peux vous dire la chose
suivante, c'est que euh début 2017, je
me suis dit, je vais essayer d'expliquer
mes choses en vidéo, mes théories en
vidéo. Donc, j'ai créé 28 vidéos en 2017
et euh je sais pas mais ça représente 50
he de de visionnage ce trucl. Alors
effectivement aux téléspectateurs,
aux internautes, je dirais "Allez voir
ces vidéos Génus" et à ce moment-là vous
allez tout comprendre. Pourquoi ? Ben
parce que quand on on comprend bien, on
maîtrise bien un sujet, c'est simple.
Vous savez la la nature, elle a tendance
à être simple. Quand c'est affreusement
compliqué, c'est que c'est on n'est pas
dans le dans le droit fil, quoi. Donc ce
sont des idées relativement simples,
subtiles, hein, euh qui donnent des
diplom les mathématiques, c'est
l'écriture, c'est la façon dont on écrit
les choses. Et c'est pas parce que c'est
écrit de façon compliquée que ça marche.
Il faut que les idées de base soient soi
soient solides. Donc là-dedans, vous les
gens trouveront une présentation
iddactique, vulgarisée, à coup d'image.
Je me suis dit tiens, si je prenais les
ingénieurs, si je prenais les étudiants,
si je prenais la première année lissance
de physique et de math, ça correspond à
ce qu'on appelle le niveau matsup. Faut
savoir la trigonométrie, qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'une dérivée première, seconde,
une équation différentielle, un
logarithme ? Voyez, un petit outillage
comme ça, ça fait un peu penser à ce
qu'on trouve dans un magasin de
bricolage. Vous voyez la la le
tournevis, la perceuse et cetera. Le
type, il a son petit matériel
mathématique et ben avec ça, on explique
tout. Vous savez avec ça plus les
matrices mais on a 99 % de la physique
théorique. Le reste c'est beaucoup de
fumée, beaucoup de choses compliquées.
Par contre, il y a une chose
effectivement qui est dure à avaler,
c'est l'aspect géométrique. Et vous
savez que on peut dire que les grands
progrès, les grands sauts de la physique
sont de nature géométrique. Par exemple,
vous prenez 1905 avec la relativité
restreinte. Tout d'un coup, vous avez un
bonhomme Einstein qui dit "On peut pas
aller plus vite que la vitesse de la
lumière."
Alors même maintenant, qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire un truc comme ça ? Ça veut
dire que quand on déplace dans le
cosmos, il y a des l'épistémoph avec un
sifflet qui veut dire attention, on peut
pas aller plus vite. Non, c'est très
très subtil. Ça veut dire qu'on vit dans
un espace de Minkowski. Qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'un espace de Minkovski ? Et
ben, c'est un espace où le carré de
l'hypoténuse est égal à la différence
des carrés des deux autres côtés. On n'y
comprend rien. Alors, on pourrait dire
"Mais est-ce que vous comprenez ?" Non,
je comprends pas plus que vous. Je suis
pas câblé pour cet espace de Minkovski,
j'en ai pas l'intuition physique.
D'ailleurs, vous savez quand vous avez
vu passer Tien Clin la dernière fois,
moi j'ai trouvé que c'était intéressant
parce qu' il a situé justement cette
espèce de dialogue entre le matériel
scientifique et ce que les gens pensent.
Et en fait, les scientifiques fabriquent
des trucs qui sont en contradiction avec
l'intuition, hein. Franchement, la
relativité récente, c'est pas intuitif
du tout. Alors, moi, je dirais dans un
truc comme ça, je pourrais résumer ça
avec la formule calculé. Il y a rien à
voir. C'est c'est comme si c'est pas le
flic dit circuler, il y a rien à voir.
Calculez, ne cherchez pas à faire
d'imag.
Donc autrement dit, qu'est-ce que fait
le physicien qui manie la relativité
restreint ? Il sait faire marcher ses
maths, c'est tout. Voilà. Et alors
après, bah vous avez la relativité
générale, c'est pas common non plus. Et
après donc ce que j'ai moi dû imaginer
pour rendre compte de cette histoire de
masse positive et de masse négative et
ben il y a saut géométrique là-dedans.
Alors j'ai essayé de donner une image
mais vous savez les images elles sont
fausses. C'est comme enité restreinte en
disant je peux bien vous donner les
images mais ça va vous donner une petite
idée des choses mais c'est pas vraiment
comme ça que ça se passe. Je crois que
l'image peut-être la moins fausse ce
serait de dire l'univers de la
relativité générale c'est une
hypersurface. Et bien c'est du perf
surface. Considérons qu'à un endroit et
un envers.
Alors effectivement quand vous prenez en
mathématique on pour nous une surface
c'est à deux dimensions. Mais pour un un
mathématicien il y a des hypersurfaces à
trois dimensions. À 4, à 5, à 19. Bon
ben cette notion d'endroit et en vert,
elle marche à des nombres de dimensions
supplémentaires. Donc là-dedans, ben
vous avez un univers avec qu'on pourrait
dire un endroit et un envers. Alors
effectivement, imaginez que quand vous
déplacez pour un un point A, un point B,
et ben en partant de là, j'ai une
certaine dimension, une certaine
longueur. Mais en allant en dessous, la
façon de mesurer n'est pas la même. Le
mètre à ruban est pas le même. D'un
côté, on aura des graduations très
serrées, ce qui fait qu' ça va
représenter une distance de temps. Et
l'en c'est pour le court. Alors
effectivement la science-fiction
représente ça avec des courbures, des
trous de verre. Non non c'est pas comme
ça que ça fonctionne. Alors maintenant
je crois qu'il faut aborder une question
essentielle. Pourquoi est-ce que les
gens disent les masses négatives ça peut
pas exister ? Alors l'été dernier au
mois d'août je suis un colloque de
cosmologie à Paris le cosm le colloc
cosmo 17. J'ai pu y aller grâce au sous
que m'ont passé les internautes. Je suis
allé aussi à Francfort grâce au sous que
m'ont parlé les internautes parce que
j'ai jamais eu un sous de crédit. Je
veux dire le la grande fierté du CNRS,
c'est privé de crédit pendant 40 ans.
Formidable. Bon làà un moment j'ai dit
"Écoutez, j'aimerais bien aller des
collocs." Les gens m'ont envoyé de
l'argent. Formidable. Bon alors je suis
allé à ce cololloque en 2017. J'ai eu
une communication qui a été présentée
sous forme d'un poster et puis ma fois
j'ai essayé de parler un peu avec des
gens. Je me rappelle il y avait un prix
Nobel, je sais plus comment il
s'appelle, j'ai oublié son nom. Je me
suis dit il faut que j'achète de coincer
ce type. Alors en fin de séance, je le
branche, j'essaie de lui expliquer ce
truclà. Ce type, il va vers la caféria,
il se retourne même pas. Il me dit
simplement les masses négatives, on a
montré que ça marchait pas à cause de
l'effet way. Je dis oui mais moi j'ai un
un contexte géométrique différent. Il
s'est fait un café, il est parti, il a
même pas tourné la tête. Donc pour vous
dire une chose, c'est que les masses
négatives, le type qui fait ça, c'est un
crackpot, c'est un pété, c'est un félé.
Voilà comme vous disz, c'est un félé. Ah
! Alors euh pourquoi ? Et bien parce que
vous avez un cosmologiste en 1957 qui
s'appelle Herman Bondi. Alors la
cosmologie, c'est l'équation d'Instein.
Là, vous l'avez là-haut, hein. Voilà.
Donc, à ce moment pour le moment, c'est
ça la cosmologie. On a rien trouvé
d'autre. Alors, Herman dit se dit
qu'est-ce qui se passe si j'essaie de
mettre des masses négatives là-dedans ?
Alors, mettre des masses négatives,
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette équation
là ? Comment elle fonctionne ? Ben là,
vous avez un second membre qui
représente la contenue d'énergie
matière. Là, je mets des masses
positives et puis ça c'est comment une
autre masse positive va se comporter,
hein. Là, j'ai le champ et là, j'ai la
petite particule témoin. Alors, telle
qu'elle est fifu cette équation là, ça
signifie que la masse positive masse
négative va se comporter de la même
façon. Autrement dit, si je mens une
masse positive, elle attire à la fois
les masses positives et les masses
négatives. Si je prends une masse
négative, elle va les repousser. Donc à
ce moment-là, on a le paradoxe suivant.
Je prends deux masses, une positive et
une négative. Et bien la masse positive
fout le camp poursuivie par la masse
négative. C'est magnifique. Et alors en
plus, elle foutent le camp avec une
vitesse uniformément accélérée et
l'énergie se conserve le 1 de MV2
puisque la vitesse puisque la masse est
négative. Donc on peut pas faire
physique un truc comme ça. Et Bondi
montre ça en 57, tout le monde conclut
donc c'est pas possible. Voilà et ça
fait 60 ans que ça dure. Alors la
démarche consiste à dire mais comment
peut-on considérer que des particules de
masse positive et négative réagissent de
la même façon quand elles sont dans un
champ de gravité ? Il y a pas de raison.
Alors si elles réagissent pas de la même
façon, ah, c'est qu'alors elles
correspondent à des métriques
différentes. Et s'il y a deux métriques,
alors il y a deux équation de champ
couplé. Et ça, c'est les équations JPP.
Ça c'est des travaux qui commencent en
94. Bon, tout est basé là-dedans et
là-dedans, il y a tout ce qu'il faut. Il
y a une dégréation dans le grand gène et
cetera. Bon, moi j'incite les gens à
aller regarder mes vidéos parce que en
quelques phrases comme ça, on peut pas
expliquer tout ça. Mais ça marche très
bien. Alors, à ce moment-là, la question
qu'on pourrait se dire "Oui, mais
qu'est-ce que vous faites des
vérifications locales dans la générale
?" Ben, quand on regarde ces équationsl
elles vous secrètent le loi
d'interaction. Par exemple, quand on
prend l'équation d'Einstein, elle
contient la loi de Newton. La loi en 1
2. Ça se voit pas, hein. C'est pas c'est
pas facile à montrer. Mais enfin, tous
les spécialistes savent. La loi de
Newton est là-dedans. Maintenant, ici,
ben on a deux lois de Newton. On a
Newton et antinon. C'est-à-dire que vous
avez les masses positives s'attirent
suivant la Newton, les masses négatives
s'attirent selon le Newton et les masses
de signes opposés se repoussent. Alors,
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce paradoxe
runway ? Et bien, à ce moment-là,
j'aurais ici une particule négative, ici
une particule positive et c'est ça.
Voilà.
et les particules négatives se
repoussent.
Ça c'est le modèle Einstein. Et alors le
modèle
Janus, bah c'est pas pareil. Là, elle se
repousse
et là elle s'attire. Donc la loi est
changée. Et à ce point-là, bon bah déjà
vous avez un principe qui est le
principe d'action et réaction. Quand A
agit sur B, B agit sur A. Bon, ça ça
viole le le modèle Einstein viole le
principe d'action à réaction. Là, il est
reconstitué. Donc, c'est un truc un peu
plus sain. Donc, vous avez un truc à ce
moment-là où les masses de signes
opposés s'excluent mutuellement. Alors,
ça veut dire que là où il y a des masses
positives, on se débarrasse des masses
négatives. Exemple, le système solaire.
Est-ce qu'il y a des masses négatives
dans le système solaire ? Il y en a très
très peu. Donc autrement dit, si il y a
très peu de masse négative, ça signifie
que ce terme qui se trouve là, je
l'enlève hein. He vous avez l'équation
d'Instein comme ça, l'équation R+- 1/2
de R + G+u
et puis il reste juste qui ? T+ minu.
Bah qu'est-ce que c'est ça ? C'est
l'équation d'Instein. Autrement dit, le
modèle Génus vérifie toutes les
observations locales. Sympathique, hein
? Bon, alors ensuite et ben qu'est-ce
qu'on peut tirer d'un truc comme ça ? Et
bien, l'accélération de l'univers. Vous
le trouvez dans le papier qu'on a publié
avec DAustinid. Dégagini qui s'est tapé,
c'est un type avec qui je travaille
depuis 20 ans, c'est lui qui s'est tapé
ce développement et tout tout se et ça
marche vachement bien. Vous avez une
courbe comme ça avec les points
expérimentaux, punaise, ça marche
vachement bien. Donc explication de
l'accélération de l'univers. Bon
ensuite,
vous avez donc un phénomène qui
s'appelle l'effet lantigravitationnel
inverse. rend compte dirait que pour le
modèle Janus, on pourrait dire quel est
l'aspect observationnel dont Janus ne
rend pas compte. C'est une prétention,
ça vous je
ça rencontre de des trucs classiques et
ensuite il y a pas de contradiction avec
l'observation. Ça prouve que c'est plus
proche de la nature que le modèle
d'hagia.
Alors pour vendre ça, c'est terrible.
Comment vous vous rendez compte ? Quand
j'ai voulu faire un papier comme ça,
je m'y suis pris en 2013, je me suis dit
bon, je vais reprendre une campagne de
publication. Alors, quand vous je vous
citais tout à l'heure 1994,
le premier système d'équation couplé que
j'avais publié, 48 essais. 48 essais, ça
m'a pris 4 ans parce qu'à l'époque
c'était les envois postaux. Alors, on
envoie une revue, on demande 48 essais.
Finalement, c'est passé dans une
chimento. Bon là, je me suis dit en
2013, je réessayie 50 essais, ça va plus
vite à cause de la messagerie
électronique mais vous avez par exemple
une revue qui s'appelle astronomie
astrophysi parce que quand vous avez les
échanges de mail, vous avez les heures
et vous voyez le moment où le type avoyé
l'article 5 minutes. C'estàd que vous
envoyez le truc, le type reçoit, tac, il
renvoie 5 minutes. Donc les articles ne
sont ni compris. Donc pour arriver à
passer quelque chose comme ça, il faut
tomber sur un référé ouvert et
compétent. Bon, ça m'a fallu 50 essais.
Ceci étant, quand c'est passé en en
2014, le type avait vraiment compris de
quoi il s'agissait. Quand on voit le
rapport de référent, il a pigé.
Maintenant, je vous raconte pas les par
exemple, je pense à les réponses
classiques en couper collé, c'est
"Sorry, we don't publish speculative
works." Désolé, on publie pas de truc
spéculatif. Et même pour ce dernier
travail là qu'on a réussi à publier avec
DAustini, on commence au mois de
décembre en envoyant ce travail là.
Réponse : "Vous savez la revue ne publie
plus ce genre de délire technologique,
ce genre de divagation quoi, du truc
spéculatif. Moi, j'avoue que j'étais en
colère. J'ai écrit
J'ai Qu'est-ce qui se passe ? pas te
casser la gueule dans dans les pieds du
tableau.
Oui. Ou non, ça marche, ça marche. Oui.
Alors, le truc c'est que j'avoue que ça
m'a pris la tête. J'ai écrit "Mais mais
qu'est-ce qu'il vous faut de plus ?" Non
de Dieu regardez les applications
observationnelles, il y a ça, il y a ça,
il y a ça, il y a ça. J'ai vraiment
écrit ça à la serpe. Je m'attendais à me
faire virer. Non, il a soumis référé,
c'est passé. Il a fallu dire aux gens
"Mais regardez, lisez." J'ai dit "Mais
vos référés, ils lisent pas l'article.
Ils ont pas vu ça, ça sans blague."
Ils ont juste vu Jean-Pierre Petit. Ah
oui ! Ah non mais pour astronomie
astrophysique c'est if Jean-Pierre Petit
zen out vraiment il y a il y a vraiment
des revues pof virer mais tous les c'est
pas c'est pas toujours le cas.
Alors effectivement il faut être lu et
compris. Pierre 108 quand on dit lu et
compris vous dites bah écoutez voilà et
il est bien gentil le petit père
Einstein avec son équation mais
maintenant il faut en prendre deux.
Alors l'équation d'instein c'est une des
deux vous voyez hein. Voilà puis alors
Newton bah il y a Newton anti Newton. Ty
il commence à voir ça, il dit nom de
Dieu. Mais mais Janus c'est pas une
idée, c'est six ou sep idées qui vont
ensemble. Par exemple, en 88, j'ai
publié un travail qui expliquait
l'homogénéité de l'univers primitif.
Comment ? Avec un modèle à vitesse de la
lumière variable. C'est le premier hein,
c'est passé à moderne physiqueur. Ça
d'ailleurs le truc c'est que anecdote
comment j'ai réussi à publier un truc
pareil ? Bon, vous savez que j'ai
travaillé avec deux grands
mathématiciens. Le premier c'est
Jean-Marie Surieux qui est décédé en
2012 et le second Grot Dick hein le le
médaille fil de math. Bon, j'étais assez
potes avec lui. J'ai jamais parlé de ses
échanges parce qu'il voulait qu'on lui
foute la paix quoi. Bon voilà mais
j'avais cet échange avec lui. Et alors
euh
ma fois je je j'ai changé beaucoup avec
Sorio. J'ai appris énormément avec lui
et un moment euh voilà dans les textes
espagnols, je vois euh vous gagnerez
beaucoup à penser que la vitesse de
lumière était variable dans le passé,
hein.
Quelle année ça vos copains
extraterrestres qui vous envoyé ça ?
76 77 voilà. Ouais. Alors euh des
preuves de ça ? Écoutez, il y a des
vidéos, j'en parle et les vidéos, elles
sont datées, hein. Voilà
les preuves. Voulez dire que j'aurais
inventé cette histoire rétroiquement. Il
y a même un moment où j'ai dit "Écoutez,
voilà, j'ai telle telle idée, j'ai pas
encore réussi à en faire quelque chose
mais je prends date." Donc voilà. Donc
autrement dit, il y a ces textes comme
ça mais et vitesse de la lumière
variable. Bon, à ce moment-là, pourquoi
une vitesse de la lumière variable ? Ça,
on peut en parler parce que
c'est relativement facile à comprendre.
Alors, vous avez un truc, c'est que
quand vous représentez
l'expansion de l'univers comme ça, vous
rappelez, on a une courbe comme ça.
Alors, appelons ça grand. C'est la
dimension caractéristique de l'univers.
C'est le rayon du ballon qui se gonfle.
Puis alors là, bah vous avez une droite
qui est CTe, c'est l'expansion d'une
bulle à la vitesse de la lumière. Donc
autrement dit, si je représente ici le
le portrait de l'univers, j'aurai des
particules comme ça. Et cette bulle qui
a comme rayon CT, c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'horizon cosmologique. Et ici,
l'horizon est plus petit que la distance
entre les particules. Et après, cet
horizon croit comme ça, vous voyez ?
puis un moment où les particules sont
comme ça et l'horizon se chevauche donc
elle communique. Alors quand on on
constate on a constaté en 88 que
l'univers était homogène, ça impliquait
que les particules et échangaient de
l'énergie les unes avec les autres.
C'est un peu comme si vous arrivez dans
un pays, tout le monde parle la même
langue et les gens ont jamais échangé un
mot hein. C'est ça. Pour arriver à une
uniformisation, par exemple, si on parle
tous le français, c'est qu'on a quand
même parlé français entre nous. Si on
pouvait dire les gens ont complètement
isolés. Bon, alors dans cette
histoire-là, on appelle ça le paradoxe
de l'horizon. Et un paradoxe qu'on peut
euh résoudre si on se dit bah la vitesse
de la lumière, je vais la mettre en
rouge comme ça sur le graphique, bah je
vais prendre une vitesse de la lumière
qui fait ça. Alors à ce moment-là, bah
elle va croître en même beaucoup plus au
début. Donc j'aurais peut-être un
horizon cosmologique qui va faire
quelque chose comme ça.
Alors moi je je commence en me disant
bah voilà je vais prendre C qui varie en
un sur R puis je commence à des calculs
dans ne plus finir ça marchait pas.
Alors je vais en Espagne et je dis à mes
espagnols
moi j'ai essayé c'est un assureur ça
marche pas. Non non ils me disent on
leur a demandé au téléphone c'est un sur
racine de R. Est-ce que vous aviez des
contacts avec eux au téléphone ?
Avec les espagnols qui avaient des
C'était qui ces espagnols ?
Quoi ?
Des gens qui ont eu des contacts
téléphoniques.
Comment il s'appelle ?
Quoi ? Celui-là il s'appelait Dominguez.
Les autres c'était Fariols. Les autres
c'était Mais vous savez, il y a toute
l'histoire. Lisez les bouquins,
informez-vous. C'est c'est du Spielberg.
Donc voilà, un sur racine de R. Moi, je
reviens avec ce truclà, ça résout le
problème. Voilà. Bon alors donc j'ai
sorti un modèle de cosmos habita de la
lumière variable et je rencontre Jean au
12 au sport d'hiver et au 12 c'était à
l'époque conseiller de Mitran, je me
rappelle puis il était directeur de
Moderne Physique a pour la France.
Alors je parle à 12, je dis voilà j'ai
un travail qu'il faudrait que je publie
mais un truc avec la vitesse de la
lumière variable et à l'époque personne
n'avait jamais envisager un truc pareil
historiquement personne.
Alors il me dit qu'en pense Sio ? Mais
il trouve que c'est pas idiot. Il me dit
écoute si Suri est d'accord je le
publie.
Donc je suis rentré, on s'est plongé
dans mon boulot pendant des mois avec
Sourio et Sourio a fini par écrire à 12
ça tient debout et c'est passé sinon ce
serait jamais passé sans blague. Alors
après il y a eu d'autres tentatives mais
mon travail de 88 est beaucoup plus
avancé que le travail de Mayo et de
Mophat par exemple. Pourquoi ? Alors,
c'est vrai que quand on se dit je vais
fermer les vitesse de la lumière, alors
vous avez la constante de gravité, vous
avez la charge électrique, vous avez la
masse, vous avez la constante de planque
enfin et cetera. Bon et bien si on se
met à faire varier un de ces paramètres,
il y a forcément quelque chose qui
déconne les atomes peuvent se former,
les galaxies tournent par rond et
cetera. Moi, je me suis dit on va tout
faire varier ensemble. Et alors cette
relation-là et bien euh
finalement
c'est l'invariance du rapport entre la
constante de gravité et le carré de la
vitesse de la lumière. Donc le premier
fil conducteur, on va prendre ça
constant. Ensuite le les autres fils
conducteurs, c'est quoi ? Je me suis dit
quelles sont les variations conjointes
des constantes qui maintiennent qui qui
laissent invariante les équations de la
physique aléquation de la physique,
équation de Bolsman, équation de Champ,
équation d'Instein, équation de de
Schroninger, tout. Donc quelles sont les
équissent les équations variantes ? Et
bien il y a qu'une seule relation de
Jose là-dedans. C'est ce que j'ai pu
dire en 88 et après en 95. Donc ça
fonctionne. Maintenant quand je suis
allé à au colloc de Paris, un moment
j'ai essayé d'aborder cette question en
salle. Il y a un canadien qui me dit
"Écoutez, allez discuter ça avec un
étudiant, il a fait aussi des trucs."
Non non, ici on parle de supercore, on
parle de choses sérieuses quoi. Ces
trucs pour les scientifiques, ce modèle
à constante variade, c'est du pipo
alors que ça résout ce problème. Bon
voilà.
Alors voyez arriver à faire passer tout
ça cet univers avec un endroit et un
envers
dans lequel l'équation d' équations.
Ensuite
quand on remonte dans le passé les
constantes dérivent. Alors c'est assez
marrant parce que quand vous remontez
dans le passé comme ça si ça maintient
invariante les équations de la physique
alors un physicien dirait et comment je
fais pour mettre ça en évidence hein ?
Et oui, puisque c'est comme mesurer une
table en fer avec une règle en fer et la
table et la règle se dilatent de la même
façon. Bah, la seule façon, c'est
l'homogénéité cosmique. C'est ça le
signe. Et vous savez puisque Étienne C a
parlé lorsque vous l'avez interviewé,
quelle est la thèse officielle ? C'est
l'inflation. Et l'inflation, vous avez
vu que l'idée c'est que l'univers se
détend d'un facteur 10^ 50 pendant 10
mois de 35 secondes.
C'est pas mal. Et pourquoi ? Ah pourquoi
? C'est grâce à un champ. Un champ de
quoi ? Bah ce champ c'est un champ
d'inflaton.
Qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un inflaton ? Et
ben, on sait pas. C'est ce qui fermet
l'univers se dilaté. C'est
extraordinaire. C'est ça. Et ça depuis
88, c'est la seule idée que les
scientifiques ont au mains. Par exemple,
voyez euh qu'est-ce pourquoi la matière
sombre ? Il faut bien expliquer ça. Ça
existe pour telle raison. Mais pourquoi
l'inflaton et et l'inflation ? Parce que
ça explique l'université. Et moi quand
j'ai sorti ça 188 mais c'est passé
totalement inaperçu. Il aurait fallu que
je puisse aller dans des congrès que je
suis expliqué ça. C'est vrai.
Moi je suis allé à des congrès, vous
savez je suis allé à mes frais. Je suis
allé à un congrès des MHD en 83 à
Moscou. J'avais trouvé une chambre à
1500 francs avec le petit déjeuner.
Alors je m'étais payé ça avec mes sous.
le voyage, la chambre puis je me disais
je vais trouver un moyen de saucissonner
entre midi et de pas du tout. On a allé
dans une université comme j'avais pas de
ticket, j'ai passé tout le colloque en
mangeant des croissants du matin. Le
matin, je remplissais mon sac de
vilnoiserie. À midi et soir, je bouffais
des villiseries parce qu'à l'époque,
c'était la guerre froide. On avait pas
mangé dans un restaurant, ça n'existait
pas. Je me suis dit j'arrête, je
recommencerai plus. Non mais
franchement, avoir dû faire une chose
pareille, c'est pas possible. Alors
l'écologue de de Cosmo, ben je suis
jamais allé quoi. C'est tout
l'astrophysique. Alors après quand vous
avez les gens qui disent "Mais quelle
est la réaction de la communauté
scientifique ?" Mais la communauté
scientifique il faut pouvoir aller la
trouver, il faut pouvoir parler dans les
colloques. Et si vous pouvez pas vous
déplacer, c'est foutu.
Vous pouvez pas vous déplacer ou ils
veulent pas de vous ?
Mais vous savez combien ça coûte un
collocque ? 500 € d'inscription hein.
Vous allez par exemple un colloc en
Allemagne 3000 € ça vous coûte le
voyage, l'hôtel, l'inscription. OK ?
Vous allez aux États-Unis 5000.
Vous avez 5000 € comme ça à claquer pour
aller aux US sans blague hein. Non, je
m'excuse, j'ai pas.
Rappelez-moi votre retraite.
2000.
Voilà.
Voilà. Donc maintenant, bah je crois que
si je dis à des gens, j'ai envie d'aller
à tel cololloque, les internautes
m'envoient des sous et j'y vais.
Bon, revenez vous asseoir. Vous avez
fini avec le tableau là ? Oh non, parce
que je pourrais vous parler de tout ce
qu'on est en train de faire, comment on
va déterminer l'origine des fluctuations
du cosmique background, comment on
détermine le fait que la vitesse de la
lumière est 10 fois plus élevée dans ce
versant d'univers, d'où vient cette
symétrie, la dynamique galactique ? Mais
alors là, ça c'est m'intéresse beaucoup.
Euh vous savez, il y a quelque chose qui
s'appelle la terre quantique des
chambres. C'est dommage, j'espère que
Tienen Clan acceptera de parler avec moi
parce que là vraiment ça me paraît pas
gagner. Enfin bon. Alors, si vous lisez
euh un livre qui s'appelle The Quantum
Serie quantique des champs, c'est le
gars qui écrit ça, c'est Steven Wenberg,
hein. Steven Berbeck, c'est prix Nobel
de physique. Bon, alors quand vous
regardez son bouquin, page 76, vous
voyez des opérations d'inversion de
temps. Ça s'appelle opérateur
d'inversion d'espace et de temps.
Et on voit bah si on inverse le temps,
ça inverse l'énergie.
Donc ça inverse la masse et à ce moment
comme c'est pas possible on va bricoler
l'opérateur pour qu'il il évite ce son
là. Et la comment dire la phrase de de
Venberg,
c'est vraiment le mot dramatique et puis
obliged
T de la mécanique quantique et on va le
prendre antilinéaire et antiunitaire
pour qu'il n'inverse pas l'énergie. Moi
quand j'étais au colloque de Paris, j'ai
essayé de discuter avec un quanti je lui
parlais de ça, il a fini par tourner les
talons, il est parti. Par contre, j'ai
des mats qui m'ont appelé qui m'ont dit
"Nous, notre tasse de thé, c'est les
fondements mathématiques de la mécanique
quantique. Votre histoire nous
intéresse." OK, mais on travaille
ensemble. Voilà. Alors, il y a ça puis
il y a plein d'autres choses quoi.
Bon, vous voulez que je me rasseille ?
Non, je me rasser
mais je vous dis tout ça que les gens a
voir les vidéos quoi. C'est ce que je
présente là ça ça passe pas.
Vous faites référence dans une de vos
vidéos que vous avez du mal à vous
inscrire parce que vous avez pas de
laboratoire.
Exact. Exa je vais vous donner un
exemple.
Vous pouvez pas mettre ancien du CNRS,
ça fonctionne pas.
Ah non non non non, ça marche pas. Euh
il y a un truc par exemple, c'est que
euh on vient d'avoir un truc accepté à
Astrovican Space Science,
la revue écrit euh "Nous vous demandons
de mettre cet article sur Arxive qui est
la le site de présentation de de
travaux. Mais je peux pas être sur
Axive. Pour Axif, il faut deux choses.
Il faut un parin, ça j'en ai un, il
s'appelle Corda, c'est un fier
théoricien italien. il a le statut de de
parrain. Donc je lui dis "Est-ce que tu
veux me parrainer ?" Pas de problème.
Mais il faut un laboratoire
d'affectation. Quand vous inscrivez, on
vous demande dans quelle formation de
recherche êtes-vous. Si vous dites "Moi,
vous savez, je suis à la retraite, non,
ça marche pas." Alors, effectivement,
ces jours-ci, quand je vais rentrer
là-bas chez moi, je vais réessayer de
m'inscrire sur Archive. Je vais mettre
je sais pas par exemple le laboratoire
d'astrophysique de Marseille où j'étais
parce que il existe un statut ou CNRS où
à ce moment-là on dit aux gens ben vous
pouvez être chercheur associé chercheur
extérieur. Vous savez le pour le le papi
qui a envie de continuer à suivre les
séminaires, bon ben il fait partie du
labo mais il il ne participe pas aux
discussions mais il peut être là. Alors
moi je suis allé à Marseille, j'ai
rencontré le directeur disce que dehors
virer avant même que ça commence.
Pourquoi
faut lui demander ?
Et j'ai demandé, il y a pas un labo de
France qui acceptera pas. Je pense que
je vais venir pour attirer à Moscou. Les
Russes me diront il y a pas de problème
voilà l'université de Moscou sera ravi
ou les costos stovac les français
personne. J'ai écrit à François Scomble
académicienne Tibou d'amour personne.
Alors en prend la en prenant la qualité
du boulot que je fais
comment je peux pas être sur Arxive
c'est c'est vertigineux. Alors, j'étais
sur ARVE il y a des années et j'avais
installé un sa nombre d'articles et tout
d'un coup, en 2013, quand j'ai sorti ces
trucs, j'ai commencé à mettre des
préprints. Tout d'un coup, mon article
est frappé de la mention on hold,
c'est-à-dire suspendu. Ah, alors je
regarde, qu'est-ce que c'est on hold ?
Oh, ça veut dire que un ou plusieurs
modérateurs ont estimé que ceci, que ça
Ah bon ? Alors, soyez patients. Alors,
au bout d'un mois, je dis mais quelle
est la décision ?
Et finalement euh ça arrive en disant
voilà euh l'article a été retiré du
compte, il est bloqué.
Alors j'ai envoyé un deuxième article,
j'en ai envoyé 17. J'avais un compte
Arxive avec 17 articles bloqués. C'est
pas mal.
Traita de quoi ? partout, la structure
spirale, la stabilité gravitationnelle,
la dévelation, tout ce que j'avais fait
17 articles, c'était assez marrant,
c'était comique. Et un moment, j'ai reçu
un truc en disant voilà nous avons
effacé vos articles de du compte,
n'essayez pas de les représenter car
vous perdriez tout accès à Arciive. Et
il m'était demandé une chose, c'était de
les publier d'abord dans une revue
comité de lecture avant de pouvoir les
mettre là-dessus.
C'est exactement l'inverse. Artif, c'est
pour publier avant. C'est des préprints.
Moi, c'est des postprint.
Et là, en principe, ce travail là doit
pouvoir être installé sur la section
Astroph c'estàd astrophysique. La
section astrophysique. Je je suis barré
là-dedans.
Bon, on arrive à la fin de notre
interview.
Ouais.
Euh, on a pour habitude de demander une
bouteille à la mer pour les jeunes
générations.
On a quoi ? demander
une bouteille à la mer pour les jeunes
générations, un conseil pour les jeunes
générations.
On vous on vous laisse y réfléchir
pendant une minute.
Mais moi moi ce que je dirais aux jeunes
générations,
qu'est-ce que vous pensez des fake news
?
Ah ben je vais vous dire la chose
suivante. Mon site est classé parmi les
fake news par le site du monde.
Faut dire que il y a des trucs un peu
chauds sur votre site quand même. Non
attendez ça veut dire quoi chaud ? Ça
veut dire quoi chaud ? C'est quoi chaud
?
Tout est sourcé carré chez vous
quoi.
Tout est sourcé carré.
Non mais attendez,
est-ce que tout est sourcé ? Tout est
carré
sourcé. Trouvez-moi un article où je dis
des conneries. C'est quoi le
le monde si vous il vous a classé en
orange, en rouge, en quoi ?
Mais je dérange.
Quelle couleur il vous a classé ?
Ah bah je suis fake news. Je me rappelle
plus mais enfin le site Jeanvit bou
voilà. Alors probablement que quand
Macron va passer sa loi, je vais être
bayonné quoi. Il y a pas de problème. Au
quel cas je je créerai un site Peter
Small par exemple. SM point
parce que vous abordez euh les OVNIS le
11 septembre le 11 septembre le 11
septembre nom de Dieu par exemple ça
c'est la carrément c'est les fake news.
Dites une chose pareille vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec les théories officielles.
Oh catastrophe ! Vous connaissez notre
ami Alix, vous savez c'est assez marrant
parce que vous savez vous savez quand
est-ce qu' est né Ropen ne fond ?
Il y a un truc c'est que un moment il y
avait un un milliardaire américain, je
me rappelle plus comment il s'appelle,
il avait été sensibilisé par cette
histoire là, il avait financé un colloc
Wald of Astoria et il avait financé il
on avait filmé toutes les conférences de
ce truclà. il a fait des DVD et puis il
m'avait mis des DVD partout et tout d'un
coup on voit un site internet en anglais
fran droite. C'est un mec d'extrême
droite lui. Non
pas du tout pas du tout. Non non non
non. Il était pas d'extrême droite du
tout. Simplement
comment dire ? Il parlait de la pilule
rouge, vous savez dans dans Matrix quoi.
Vraiment c'est bon. Et donc il a financé
ce truclà et on voit tout d'un coup sur
internet
cette conférence, il y avait 3 heur de
truc en plusieurs langues. Et moi je dis
aux internautes, "Dépêchez-vous de
sauver ce trucl, moi je sais pas le
faire." Et effectivement Alix l'a fait.
Et euh 48 heures après Maxi toutes les
sites étaient à mais
il y a deux trois sites qui se sont ils
avaient sauvé la version française la
version anglaise mais il y avait du
japonais, il y avait plusieurs langues
comme ça et c'est comme ça que c'est
parti.
Revenons, revenons à nos moutons. Le
conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Bah le conseil des jeunes générations,
c'est
comment dire ? Ayez confiance dans le
fait que nous sommes à la veille de
découverte fantastique. N'écoutez pas
les gens qui ronronnent dans des
conneries quoi. On est là en train de
vous dire "Ah, vous savez on va bientôt
savoir de quoi fait la matière sombre,
bientôt savoir de quoi fait l'énergie
noire, mais bientôt savoir comment
fonctionne le tuberc." Non, il y a des p
de la science qui sont des conneries
et franchement mais il faut avoir du
culot au nom de Dieu. Vous savez, moi je
dirais qu'est-ce que je suis ? Je suis
un saventurier. Vous savez dans ma vie
j'ai fait
savantfé.
Oui. Non savant. Non non c'est vous qui
ressentez ce trucl à savant à
saventurier.
Regardez par exemple moi je me suis
intéressé à l'égyptologie. Bon ben, j'ai
trouvé comment marchait la coudé
égyptienne que c'est finalement un truc
qui qui fonctionne comme un calculateur.
J'ai publié ça dans une revue
d'égyptologie. Ouais. Et puis il y a des
trucs, j'ai compris comment marchaient
les bateaux égyptiens. Je vais en
construire un, je vais naviguer avec.
Mais il faut faire les choses de Dieu.
Vous rappelez Torerdal qui a traversé le
Pacifique avec son radeau. Voilà la
recherche. C'est ça. Faites les choses
de Dieu.
Jean-Pierre Petit merci. On demande à
notre communauté de bien travailler sur
notre plateforme de fact checking. Du
moins la plateforme de de fact checking
Capitain Fact. Merci d'être venu.
Mais prochaine fois le nucléaire tout ce
que vous voulez. Là prochaine fois
est-ce que vous allez vous faire allumer
quoi ? C'est ça.
Couper.
[Musique]